RESOURCE IN WATER WILL NOW COME
TO ORDER- GOOD MORNING IN
RESPONSE TO THE COVE IN
NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
AND EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE IS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THE PUBLIC
CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. TO ALLOW
THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TO TWO HEARING ROOMS TO THE
EXTENT THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOWING WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE LINE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENTS THE PARTITION
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON
OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE IT WILL
BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND
I WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS. EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO EIGHT
NINE FIVE THREE. AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. SEVEN ZERO FIVE SIX
NINE ZERO NINE. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO
TELECONFERENCE IN THAT THE
SYSTEM WORKS PLEASE REFER TO
THE SENATOR COMMITTEE WEBSITE.
WE MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT
TO DIAL ONE THEN ZERO FOR
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION. PLEASE
PRESS THIS ONLY ONE TIME AND
WAIT PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR
TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER
THIS CAN BE A SHORT WAIT ONCE
YOU RECEIVE HER LINE NUMBER YOU
WILL WAIT IN THE QUEUE FOR THE
MODERATOR CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER. AT THAT TIME TO BE A
MUTED AND YOU ARE NOW READY TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. WILL BE
ALLOWING FIFTEEN MINUTES FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT FOR BOTH SUPPORT
ENOUGH ON EACH BILL. TO HEAR
FROM AS MANY PEOPLE AS TIME
PERMITS WE ASK YOU TO PLEASE
SIMPLY STATE YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION AND YOUR POSITION
ON THE BILL UNLESS YOU ARE LEAD
TO TESTIMONY. PLEASE NOTE THAT
IN ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY IN AVOID IF COULD STICK
FEEDBACK YOU MUST MUTE THE
DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT'S
IMPORTANT WE HEAR FROM YOU AND
WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
ALL MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING A
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY IN ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DISRUPTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTION SPEED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO MAKE.
TO STREAMLINE HEARING
PROCESSING CONDUCTOR HEARINGS
IN THIS CLOSE TO MANNER- SAME
MANNER AS IS CUSTOMARY THERE
MAY BE SOME LAG TIME FOR
PARTICIPANTS WERE ADJUSTING TO
THE NEW USE OF ONLINE TOOLS OR
TECHNOLOGY SO PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL. AND PATIENTS ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE
HEARD- FOLKS WE HAVE A SEVEN
BILLS ON TODAY'S AGENDA AND TWO
OF THEM ARE ON PROPOSED CONSENT
THAT'S FILE ITEM ONE AB SEVENTY
TWO AND FILE ITEM FOUR. EIGHTY
SIX NINETY TWO. I ALSO KNOW
THAT CENTER GROUP WILL NOT BE
ATTENDING TODAY AND OUR VICE
CHAIR CENTER JONES. HAS TO.
NAVIGATE TO COMMITTEE HEARINGS
THE SAME TIME SO YOU MAY BE. IN
AND OUT- FOR THE MOMENT WE'RE
GOING TO CONVENE AS A SUB
COMMITTEE- SO WE WILL HOLD OFF
ON ESTABLISHING FULL QUORUM-
AND- WE WILL YOU MISTER WITH
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. I HAVE TO
WAIT UNTIL THERE'S A QUORUM I
THINK. YOU KNOW WHY WE ALLOW
PRESENTATION THEN ON THE AUTHOR
WHO IS HERE WITH US CAN I ASK
YOU JUST QUICKLY SPENT YOU SAID
WE HAD SEVEN BILLS IN MY
GENESIS EIGHT SO SOMEBODY
WITHDRAWN A BILL. FIVE SEVEN ON
MINE. PLEASE ABOUT WATER WITH
US ONE SECOND WHICH ONE DOLLAR.
BUT IT IS. IT IS THE- BECAUSE
IT AT EIGHTEEN FIFTEEN EIGHTY-
IT WAS FIVE FIVE OKAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ADJUSTED DILUTED.
EIGHT ANALYSIS BY THE FORMER
FILE ITEM FIVE. I BELIEVE THAT
THOSE IN POSITIONS HERE IN
CANADA OKAY- WHAT WILL
COMMUNITIES SUBCOMMITTEE ALLOW
PRESENTATION AT THIS MOMENT SO-
EVEN THOUGH WE'RE NOT IN TOTAL
ORDER I SEE IS A MEMBER
ARAMBULA HERE. I'M SORRY MR
MAYS I DID NOT SEE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER- AB FOUR FOUR TWO SIR.
THANK YOU. BYE WELL THE THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND- CENTERS-
HE'S PRESENT AB FOUR FOUR TWO
METROPOLITAN WATER DISTRICT OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA IS THE
PRIMARY WHOLESALE WATER
SUPPLIER FOR SOMETHING
CALIFORNIA SERVICE- LA ORANGE
COUNTY RIVERSIDE SALMON YOU
KNOW SAN DIEGO ON PRINTER
VENTURA COUNTIES IT IS CHARGED
WITH PROVIDING RELIABLE
SUPPLIES WATER FOR NINETEEN
MILLION RESIDENTS. THE SURFACE
MINING AND RECLAMATION ACT
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS SMARA
CURRENTLY REQUIRES THAT
RECLAMATION PLANS BE SUBMITTED
APPROVED EACH COUNTY WHICH CAN
INEVITABLY LEAD TO VERY
PROCESSES AND TIMELINES AB FOUR
FOUR TO AUTHORIZE METROPOLITANS
TO SUBMIT A MASTER RECLAMATION
PLAN THAT IS LIMITED TO
ACTIVITIES ON ITS OWN LAND AND
INFRASTRUCTURE WITHIN THE SIX
COUNTIES THE STATE MINING AND
GEOLOGY BOARD. WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSERVATION TO
ENSURE REGULATORY CONSISTENCY
IN IMPLEMENTATION I'D LIKE TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE IN
DEPARTMENT STAFFER SUGGESTING
MEMONS TO CLARIFY THIS PROCESS
THAT THE BILL SETS OUT I'M
HAPPY TO ACCEPT THOSE MOMENTS
AT TODAY SELECT INTRODUCED
MELINDA STAHL THE SENIOR
ENVIRONMENTAL SPECIALIST FOR
METROPOLITAN TO SPEAK FURTHER
ON THE BILL. EVERY SEPARATE
BECAUSE I BUT WHEN THE TIME
COMES. THANK YOU SO MUCH
ASSEMBLYMEMBER- WHEN I GO TO
YOUR- LEAD WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
OPERATOR I THINK WE GOOD
MORNING TERRY YEAH PLEASE. GOOD
MORNING CHESTER AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE AND THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAYES FOR YOUR
SUPPORT AND LEADERSHIP ON THIS
ISSUE. THE METROPOLITAN WATER
DISTRICT APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH STAFF
FROM SENATOR STERN'S OFFICE AND
TO AMEND EIGHTY FOUR FOUR TWO.
AND SUPPORTS THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENT. AS BACKGROUND TO THE
COMMITTEE. DEFAULTED WATER
DISTRICT OF SOUTHERNCALIFORNIA
WAS ESTABLISHED IN NINETEEN
TWENTY EIGHT AS A SPECIAL
DISTRICT TO PROVIDE A RELIABLE
WATER SUPPLY TO OUR GROWING
SEVEN CALIFORNIA. YOU CONTINUE
TO MEET DEMANDS OF A GROWING
POPULATION METROPOLITAN HAVE
CAN HAS GROWN TO INCLUDE AN
EXTENSIVE RANGE OF
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT DELIVERS
HIGH QUALITY WATER. TO ITS
TWENTY SIX MEMBER AGENCIES. WHO
IN TURN SERVE APPROXIMATELY
NINETEEN MILLION PEOPLE IN
THREE HUNDRED CITIES AND
UNINCORPORATED AREAS ACROSS SIX
COUNTIES AND SEVEN CALIFORNIA.
WHEN METROPOLITAN CONSTRUCTION
OF THE COLORADO RIVER AQUEDUCT
AND BEGAN OPERATION IN NINETEEN
FORTY ONE IT RETAINS THE TITLE
TO THE LAND BENEATH AND
ADJACENT TO THE AQUEDUCT
INCLUDING THE STONE GRAVEL AND
SAND. TO THIS DAY MUCH ABOUT
THE USE OF MATERIALS FROM
DESIGNATED BAR OKAY. TO RESTORE
PREPARE PROTECT AND MAINTAIN
BERMAN ACCESS ROADS AND
PIPELINES THROUGHOUT ITS
DISTRIBUTION SYSTEM. THE
SERVICE MINING AND RECLAMATION
ACTORS MARK PROVIDES FOR THE
REGULATION OF SURFACE MINING
OPERATIONS TO ENCOURAGE MENTAL-
OF MINERAL PRODUCTION AND
CONSERVATION. AND TO ENSURE IT
MIGHT LAND A RECLAIMED TO
USABLE CONDITION TO PREVENT
ENVIRONMENTAL EFFECTS AND
ENSURE PUBLIC HEALTH AND
SAFETY. THE COUNTIES HAVE BEEN
DELEGATED AUTHORITY FOR SMART
COMPLIANCE AND SERVE AS LEADING
THE- CANADA'S BERNADINO
NOTIFIED METROPOLITAN THAT IT
NEEDED TO COMPLY WITH MARK FOR
THE USE OF ITS MATERIAL. USED
TO REPAIR AND MAINTAIN ITS
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE. EVEN
AFTER RIVERSIDE COUNTY FOLLOWED
SUIT. COMPRISES MARANA COUNTY
BY COUNTY BASIS WILL BE COSTLY
AND INEFFICIENT REQUIRING THE
PREPARATION ESTEPA RECLAMATION
PLANS ASSOCIATED SICK WITH
DOCUMENTS. REGULATORY PERMITS
AN ANNUAL INSPECTIONS.
METROPOLITAN IS SEEKING SPECIAL
STATUS UNDER SMARA SO THAT IT
CAN DEVELOP A SINGLE MASTER
RECLAMATION PLAN THAT WILL BE
SUBMITTED TO THE STATE MINING
AND GEOLOGY BOARD FOR REVIEW
AND APPROVAL. THE PROPOSED
LEGISLATION WOULD NOT IN THAT
METROPOLITAN CHRIS MARTIN PLANT.
METROPOLITAN SINGLE MASTER.
PLAN WOULD INCLUDE ALL IT WHICH
THE PARASITES COMPLY WITH CIGNA
AND PROVIDE REGULATORY
CONSISTENCY ACROSS COUNTY.
REPORTS WOULD BE SUBMITTED TO
THE STATE MINING AND GEOLOGY
BOARD IN ADDITION TO EACH
INDIVIDUAL COUNTY AND THE STATE
MINING AND GEOLOGY BOARD UNDER
THE DIRECTION OF THE DEPARTMENT
OF CONSERVATION WHAT
PERFORMANCE SECTIONS. BUDGET
BOLTON WOULD REIMBURSE THE
BOARD AND THE DEPARTMENT FOR
ALL ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS. IN
RECOGNITION OF METROPOLITAN
JUNIOR IN FREQUENT USE OF
MATERIALS FOR REPAIR AND
MAINTENANCE OF THE FACILITIES.
EIGHTY FOUR POINT YOU ALSO
EXEMPTS METROPOLITAN FROM AS
FAR AS I DON'T MIND PROVISIONS
BUT INCLUDES MAIN AND MEASURES
MAINTENANCE MEASURES TO ENSURE
PUBLIC SAFETY AND COMPLIANCE
pWATER INFRASTRUCTURE REQUIRES
COORDINATED REGULATORY
COMPLIANCE EIGHTY FOUR FOUR TO
ENSURE THE PROTECTION
MAINTENANCE AND REPAIRS OF
METROPOLITAN THE PROJECTOR.
JOINT SURE SAFE AND RELIABLE
WATER DELIVERIES TO MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIA HOMES. BUSINESSES
AND FARMS AND COST EFFICIENT
AND ECONOMICALLY RESPONSIBLE
WAY. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION AND I WOULD BE
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE. AB FOUR FOUR TWO.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY I THINK
THAT'S OUR ONLY LEAD SUPPORT
WITNESS HERE- SO WE'LL GO.
OPERATOR OPEN LINES FOR-
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. I DON'T
SEE WHICH TO VOICE SUPPORT FOR
A BI FOR. SORRY BUT WE SUPPORT
FOR A BI. APOLOGIES I DON'T SEE
ANYONE IN THE HEARING ROOM
WHICH ONE TO CHECK ON THE
ALTERNATE ROOMS. NOTHING THERE
OKAY NOTHING ELSE IN THE ROOM
PLEASE OPEN UP MY APOLOGIES
OPERATE. NO WORRIES. IF YOU'D
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
FOUR FOUR TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE
BEEN IS ZERO AT THIS TIME WE'RE
GONNA START WITH WE HAVE FIVE
IN Q. CURRENTLY WE'RE GONNA
START WITH LINE NUMBER SIXTY
FOUR THAT SIX FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MY APOLOGIES HAVING
TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES OPENING
THAT LINE ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
OPERATOR YOU WANT TO GO TO THE
NEXT LINE MAYBE THAT PERSON CAN
RE QUEUE. OKAY SORRY ABOUT THAT
WOULD ALIGN NUMBER SEVENTY
SEVEN ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO THIS IS CHRISTY FOY ON
BEHALF OF THE THREE DOLLARS
MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF EIGHTY FOUR
FORTY THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GALLAGHER LINE NUMBER SIXTY SIX
SIX SIX OR ONE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBER STATES
AND I AGREE WITH THAT- SINGLE
PAYER OF SENTIMENT ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL
UTILITIES ASSOCIATION ALSO TOOK
PART. BIGGER MUCH NEXT. MIX A
LITTLE LINE NUMBER. EIGHTY FIVE
EIGHT FIVE. SH GOOD MORNING TO
ME MINOR ON BEHALF OF EASTERN
MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT PLEASE
TO SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ON THE OTHER LINE NUMBER
SEVENTY SIX THAT. SEVEN SIX.
BOATWRIGHT GAMBLE TRY WOULD
LINE NUMBER NINETY TWO THEN.
NINE TO. NINETY TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. WE ARE GETTING THE
AUDIO FROM LINE NUMBER NINETY
TWO THERE'S NO ONE ELSE IN Q.
OKAY- VERY GOOD- I DON'T HAVE
WE DON'T HAVE ANY OPPOSITION
LISTED ON FILE BUT- LOOKING IN
THE. THE COMMITTEE ROOM I DON'T
SEE ANYONE ANYONE ON THE LINE'S
OPERATOR. SHE. THEY WERE IN
OPPOSITION WILLING TO TESTIFY.
DO WE SPEAK IN OPPOSITION YOU
MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND THERE'S NO ONE
SHOWING UP AT THIS TIME. OKAY
THANK YOU WILL BRING IT BACK TO
DYESS. EARLIER ON A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS OF THE AUTHOR AND THE
FIRST ONE IS THE ANALYSIS OF
MAKE SOME SUGGESTIONS EVEN
OFFERS AN ALTERNATIVE- ON PAGE
SIX AND SEVEN AND I WONDERED IF
YOU JUST WANTED TO RESPOND TO
THAT. YOU KNOW IF IT'S OKAY I
WILL HAVE OUR EXPERT I RESPOND
TO THAT IF THAT'S- THAT'S
APPROPRIATE JUST COULD YOU
PROBABLY GET A BETTER RESPONSE
FROM FROM HER THAN YOU WILL
FROM- FROM ME. NO ARE ARE. NOT
INCLINED TO TORTURE YOU. NO NO
NO IT'S TOTALLY. IT TOTALLY
FINE OKAY. BUT I WOULD SAY.
THAT THE AMENDMENTS THAT THE
AUTHOR ACCEPTED ADDRESS- THE
SOME OF THE ISSUES RAISED IN
THE ALTERNATIVES- THAT'S A
THAT'S A GOOD ADD ON TO MAYBE
HAVE THE. THE SPONSOR TALK
ABOUT WHAT- WHAT. THEY TOOK AS
AN AMENDMENTS AND WHAT THEY
DIDN'T TAKE AND WHY THEY DIDN'T
TAKE. MAYBE THAT BE A GOOD WAY
TO PHRASE THE QUESTION TO THE
QUICKER WE GET SOME- JUST ALL
THE YEAH I MISSED ALL THE DO
YOU WANT TO YOU WANT TO COMMENT
ON THAT I KNOW WE WORK WE WORK
HARD THROUGH THESE AMENDMENTS
AND- BELIEVE YOU ALL. ACCEPTED
EVERYTHING WE ASK FOR. YES AND
THANK YOU S. CENTER LATER YES
WE A WE DID ACCEPT ALL OF THE
AMENDMENTS AS REQUESTED- FROM-
FROM CENTERS OFFICE AND FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF CONSERVATION.
THAT WE WORK WITH THEM VERY
CLOSELY. TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAD ADDRESSED ALL THEIR
CONCERNS. BUT COULD YOU BRIEFLY
CHARACTERIZE WHAT THE CONCERNS
WERE AND HOW YOU DRESSED AND
I'M NOT LOOKING FOR CHAPTER AND
VERSE ON LOOKING FOR MORE
GLOBAL HEAR THEIR CONCERNS
HERE'S HOW WE ADDRESS THEM. IT
COULD BE AT EIGHTY FOUR FOUR
TWO ORIGINALLY AND WHAT IS WHAT
IS BASED ON THE- WHEN WE WERE
TRYING TO FOLLOW THE CACHE
CREEK PLANNED- BUT IT DIDN'T
REALLY AND IT DIDN'T REALLY
ENCOMPASS. ALL OF THE SMARA.
AND THE WAY THAT IT WAS WRITTEN
IT DIDN'T ACTUALLY REFER BACK
TO ALL OF SMARA SO AND SO WHAT
WE DID WAS WE REGRET THE
LANGUAGE TO MAKE IT TODAY BUT
WE WERE SUBJECT TO. ALL OF THE
REQUIREMENTS AS FAR AND THAT'S
ALSO WE JUST MADE IT MORE CLEAR
IN THE- IN THE LEGISLATION.
CARRINGTON OTHER QUESTION. AND
THAT IS THAT. BY DOING THIS-
SORT OF. HAVING A SINGLE MASTER
RECLAMATION PLANT. AND A COVER
SIX COUNTIES SOME OF WHICH ARE
REPRESENTED BY. PEOPLE ON OF
THE DIETS HERE. DOES THAT MAKE
IT HARDER FOR PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION IF YOU ARE.
SOMEBODY THAT'S BY JOSHUA TREE
AND THERE'S SOMETHING OUT
THERE. THAT IS AN ISSUE AND THE
HEARING IS HELD IN DOWNTOWN LA
OR SOMETHING DOES THAT MEAN
THAT. THAT YOU ONLY HAVE A WAY
TO ACCESS THIS PROCESS. IN ONE
LOCATION EVEN THOUGH YOU MGHT
BE IN ONE OF THE FAR FLUNG
PLACES OF ONE OF THE SIX
COUNTIES IT'S COVERED BY THIS
POINT. ASSEMBLY THE RECLAMATION
PLANS OUR OFFICE ALSO COVERED
BY THE CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY ACT WHICH DOES PROVIDE
PUBLIC PARTICIPATION- AND IT IN
A PUBLIC FORUM SO. THE PUBLIC
WOULD BE ABLE TO ADDRESS THE
RECLAMATION PLANT THEMSELVES- I
GET THE INCLUDING ANY
AMENDMENTS TO VOTE I'M ASKING
IF THE PUBLIC PARTICIPATION.
MIGHT BE VERY REMOTE TO WHERE
THE PERSON LIVES THAT'S WHAT MY
QUESTION IS. IN TERMS OF AS
THE- THAT STATE IT IS THE
PERSON WHO IS THE GROUP THAT
WOULD BE APPROVING THAT THE
RECLAMATION PLANT SO IT WOULD
BE AT THE STATE PROCESS. LEVEL
ASIDE FROM CIGNA. WELL MY
QUESTION IS STILL IF YOU'RE IN
A FAR FLUNG LOCATION IN
RELATION TO THE SMART PLANT ARE
THEY GOING TO HAVE READY ACCESS
IF THERE'S A REQUIREMENT FOR IN
PERSON PARTICIPATION THAT'S
JUST WHAT I'M DRIVING AT
BECAUSE YOU SEE IF WE WEREN'T
DOING THIS PLAN. THE THEY WOULD
BE INDIVIDUAL PROJECTS AND I
KNOW WE'RE DOING THIS TO
STREAMLINE IT SO THERE'S NOT
INDIVIDUAL PROJECTS. BUT
RELIGIOUS SAY THERE WAS A
PROJECT ON THE COLORADO RIVER.
AND TO THE ONLY IN PERSON
PUBLIC PARTICIPATION BECAUSE
YOU'VE DONE A REGIONAL PLAN IS
TO HAVE THEM GO TO LOS ANGELES
I AM JUST TRYING TO. TO GET
SOME ASSURANCE THAT WE ARE NOT
SCREENING PEOPLE AWAY FROM
PUBLIC PARTICIPATION BY
ADOPTING THIS BILL SO I. CAN
COMMENT SINCE THESE ARE
AMENDMENTS- THE INTENT HERE BY.
BRINGING ALL THIS BACK IN THIS
MARA WAS THAT THE RECLAMATION
PLAN PROCESS ITSELF WILL HAVE
WILL BE PUBLICLY NOTICED AND
THAT THERE WILL BE AT THE TO
THE EXTENT IT AS MULTI COUNTY
IMPACT IT'S GOING TO REQUIRE
THAT THEN ON A PROJECT BY
PROJECT BASIS AFTERWARDS. IT'S
NOT AS IF YOU CAN JUST- SORT OF
CATCH ALL WITH A BIG
PROGRAMMATIC HE I ARE YOU'RE
GONNA HAVE TO THEN TEAR OFF OF
THAT PLAN I THINK THEY WERE I
THINK THERE ARE SOME BORROWING
PITS AND OTHER THINGS OUT. IN
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS AREA BUT
SAY SOMETHING WERE GOING ON AND
THERE IS A RECLAMATION PROJECT
IN VENTURA COUNTY UNDER THAT
PLAN I THINK THAT WOULD. AND
THAT SPONSOR CAN CORRECT ME IF
I'M WRONG BUT THAT WOULD
ACTUALLY HAVE TO BE. SEPARATELY
NOTICED UNDERSEA CLUB THERE
WERE SIGNIFICANT IMPACT SO YOUR
TUNER D. OF A HEARING IN
VENTURA COUNTY SO THAT PEOPLE
DON'T HAVE TO GO AND SOME
RIGHT. AT THE MINISTERS OF
THAT'S TRUE THAT ANSWERS THE
QUESTION JEFF I CAN'T INTO AND
SENATOR I THINK WE HAVE- ROSIE
THOMAS AYE WITH METROPOLITAN
START THINKING ANSWER
SOMEBODY'S QUESTION KIND. OF
THING I GOT THAT DESCRIPTION
RIGHT BUT THE PROJECTS THEN CEO
EITHER HOW YOU GO THROUGH THAT
LOCAL IT WOULD HAVE TO BE
NOTICED TO THE EXTENT THEY HAVE
IMPACT LOCALLY THAT HAVE TO GO
THROUGH THEIR OWN SEQUEL
PROCESS WITH. MATT IS THE LEAD.
AGENCY AS WELL AS THE PLAN.
THAT THAT'S CORRECT. YEAH THE I
DON'T WANT BE LABOR BUT OKAY
SOME. YOU YOU YOU YOU USUALLY
ARE FOR EXAMPLE IN SANTA CLARA
COUNTY THERE'S ONE PARTICULAR
OPEN PIT MINE THAT WAS VERY
CONTROVERSIAL AND THE PLAN WAS
JUST FOR THAT MINE AND
EVERYTHING WAS NOTICED IN ALL
THE PUBLIC ACCESS WAS RIGHT
NEAR THAT MINE A. N. I'M JUST
TRYING TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
NOT IN THE INTEREST OF
STREAMLINING MOVING PEOPLE OUT
OF THE PROCESS BUT- I GOT A
YES. ITSELF THAT YES WAS THE
YES WE'RE SATISFIED AND WE CAN
GET OUT OF MY WEEDS AND GO BACK
TO OF THE CONSIDERATION OF THE
BILL ON COULD TYPE APPRECIATE
THE DILIGENCE AND- YOU KNOW.
AFFECTED YEAH CENTER ALLEN
MYSELF FROM ONE REGION ALL THE
WAY OUT TO. THE ASSEMBLY OR
MAYES IS AREA MATT IS A HUGE
SPRAWLING ENTITY SERVING MANY
CUSTOMERS SO I DON'T THINK. I
DON'T SEE ANYTHING IN THIS
LANGUAGE THAT ALLOWS MEN TO
SKIRT PUBLIC COMMENTER PROCESS
ON INDIVIDUAL PROJECTS UNDER
THIS PLAN IN THAT PARTICULAR
AREA SO- IF THERE'S ANY NEED TO
CLARIFY THAT WE CAN LOOK AT IT
BUT- I. THINK WE'RE IN PRETTY
GOOD GROUND HERE- BUT ARE THERE
ANY OTHER COMMENTS- FROM
MEMBERS QUESTIONS ANYTHING- I'D
ENTERTAIN A MOTION IF
APPROPRIATE WE HAVE TO WE DON'T
OF A QUORUM. I CANNOT ENTERTAIN
A MOTION I WOULD- BUT I WOULD
ALLOW THE AUTHOR TO. CLOSE I
JUST WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR ALL THEIR WORK ON
THIS AND IF- IF I COULD JUST
QUICKLY SAY- I THINK- THAT
SENATOR LAYERED BEING ON THIS
COMMITTEE WAS THAT A PROPER
DEPLOYMENT AT TO BE ON THIS
COMMITTEE IT'S GREAT TO HAVE
YOU. IN THE LEGISLATURE WITH
YOUR VAST AMOUNT OF EXPERIENCE
I THANK YOU FOR YOUR QUESTIONS
AND YOUR COMMENTS HAVE A
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. THIS COULD BE OUR QUORUM.
WE AND WE DO HAVE A QUORUM SO
WILL ESTABLISH THAT QUORUM AND
THEN WE WILL TAKE THAT VOTE- IT
CHIEF CONSULTANT WOULD YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. STERN
YOUR TURN HERE JONES JONES HERE
ALLEN. ALLEN HERE EGGMAN EGGMAN
HERE'S GROWTH HERTZBERG HUESO
LAYERED HERE LEARN HERE MONA WE
HAVE A QUORUM MISTER CHAIR I
WOULD MOVE THIS BILL THANK YOU
SO MUCH SO WE HAVE A MOTION
FROM SENATOR LAYERED WHICH WAS
BE TO PASS AS AMENDED BUT- BUT
FIRST AMENDED RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS-
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL FILE ITEM
VIEWS YOU BEFORE FOR. AS
PROCREATION KERN I BURN ALL A
JONES JONES HI ALAN. ALLEN ALL
RIGHT EGGMAN. EGGMAN HIGH GROSS
HERTZBERG HUESO LAYERED ON
LAYERED ALL RIGHT LIMóN. OKAY
THAT DOES FIVE VOTES REALLY THE
MEASURE ON CALL THANK YOU SAID
MR SURE WE HAVE TWO ITEMS ON
CONSENT I DON'T OF ONE AND FOUR
AND I WOULD MOVE TO CONSENT
COUNTY. GOOD OCEAN FROM CENTER
LATE ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE
CONSENT CALENDAR FILE ITEM IT-
ONE AB SEVENTY TWO AND FILE
ITEM FOR AB SIX NINE TWO STERN
HI STERN ALRIGHT JONES. ALLEN
ALL RIGHT ALAN I'D EGGMAN
EGGMAN HIGH GROWTH HERTZBERG
HUESO LAYER BY LAYER HI LIMóN.
OKAY FOUR VOTES WILL BE THE
MEASURE ON CALL FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBERS- FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE
IS A MEMBER RANDY AB FIVE FIVE
NINE MEMBERS. WELCOME. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I WOULD
FIRST LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE FRUITFUL
CONVERSATIONS WITH MY OFFICE
AND STAKEHOLDERS. WE ARE HAPPY
TO TAKE THE AMENDMENTS AND
BELIEVE THAT THEY BRING THIS
BILL TO A MUCH BETTER PLACE. AB
FIVE FIVE NINE WILL BRING AND
ADD NEW UNDER REPRESENTED
VOICES TO THE SAN JOAQUIN RIVER
CONSERVANCY BOARD. IT REFRAMES
THE FOCUS OF THE COUNTY
RESIDENTS SEATS AND MAKES OTHER
CHANGES TO ALIGN ITS OPERATIONS
AS A STATE AGENCY ALONGSIDE
OTHER CONSERVANCY'S. PUBLIC
PARKS IN AND AROUND PUBLIC.
URBAN AREAS ARE CRUCIAL FOR
BOTH MENTAL HEALTH AND CLIMATE
RESILIENCE. THE PANDEMIC HAS
MADE IT CLEAR THAT THE NEED FOR
ALL CALIFORNIANS HAVE ACCESS TO
THE SPACES. AS WELL AS THE
SEVERE LACK OF ACCESS MANY OF
OUR DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
HAVE. RESIDENTS IN UNDERSERVED
NEIGHBORHOODS IN BOTH FRESNO
AND MADERA COUNTIES FACE JUST
SUCH A PREDICAMENT. THANKFULLY
THE SAN JOAQUIN RIVER
CONSERVANCY'S MISSION TO
ACQUIRE LANDS ALONG THE SAN
JOAQUIN RIVER CONSERVE VALUABLE
HABITAT AND DEVELOP THESE LANDS
FOR THE PUBLIC BENEFIT IS A
CURATOR THIS LACK OF ACCESS.
HOWEVER TO PROVIDE THE MAXIMUM
BENEFITS TO ALL IT IS IMPORTANT
THAT DIVERSE AND MARGINALIZED
VOICES AND PERSPECTIVES HELP
GUIDE THE DECISIONS OF THE
CONSERVANCY IN AN EQUITABLE
MANNER. AB FIVE FIVE NINE
EXPANDS THE CONSERVANCY BOARD
TO INCLUDE THOSE NEW VOICES TO
REPRESENT BOTH THE BROAD
GEOGRAPHIC AND CULTURAL
DIVERSITY THAT THE SAN JOAQUIN
RIVER PARKWAY SERVICE. I WOULD
BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MAY HAVE AND
I'M JOINED TODAY BY MAYOR
SANTOS GARCIA OF THE CITY OF
MADERA AND SHARON WEAVER THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE SAN
JOAQUIN RIVER. PARKWAY
CONSERVATION CONTRAST. VERY
GOOD THANK YOU SUMMER LET'S
TURN TO- YOUR LEAD SUPPORT AND
I HAVE MISS WEAVER FIRST OR MR
GARCIA MAYOR GARCIA- IS OF THE
LIGHTS. GOOD MORNING MEMBERS-
MY NAME IS SOME CLOSELY GARCIA
AND I AM THE MAYOR OF THE CITY
OF MADERA AND A MEMBER OF THE
SAN JOAQUIN RIVER CONSERVANCY
SINCE TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN AND
I FULLY SUPPORT DR RAMBLE THE
BILL AB FIVE FIVE NINE IN ITS
PRESENT FORM. NOW I WAS VERY
SURPRISED WHEN I WAS FIRST
APPOINTED TO THE BOARD. BOB
THIS IS A CALIFORNIA STATE
BOARD THAT I WAS THE ONLY
LATINO. ON THE BOARD. AND I
STILL AM THE ONLY LET YOU KNOW
ON THE BOARD. THERE ARE
ADDITIONALLY THERE ARE NO
AFRICAN AMERICANS ON THE BOARD.
THERE ARE NO MONGOL
REPRESENTATIVES ON THE BOARD
THERE ARE NO PUNJAB THE
REPRESENTATIVES ON THE BOARD.
THIS LACK OF DIVERSITY ON THE
BOARD NEEDS TO THE LACK OF
ACCESS TO THE SAN JOAQUIN RIVER
FOR COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. AND
PEOPLE IN THE OUTLYING AREAS AS
THE REGION. SAN JOAQUIN RIVER
RIVERVIEW DR ACCESS ROAD IS
BLOCKED AND IT BARS THOSE WHO
COULD MOST BENEFIT FROM THE
KEEP GREEN SPACES ON THE RIVER
BOTTOM. FOUR YEARS THE BOARD
HAS VOTED TO DENY SCHOOL BUSES
OR PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION FROM
ENTERING THE GATES AND GOING TO
THE RIVER BOTTOM TO ENJOY THE
SAN JOAQUIN RIVER. I BELIEVE
THAT INCREASING THE NUMBER OF
MEMBERS ON THE BOARD WOULD LEAD
TO CREATING SPACES FOR PEOPLE
OF COLOR AND MORE DIVERSITY ON
THE BOARD. AND SO THEREFORE I
PLEASE ASK YOU TO PASS AB FIVE
FIVE NINE. THANK YOU MAYOR
GARCIA. MISS WEAVER. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE MISS WEAVER'S LINE WAS
HAVING SOME TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTIES WERE TRYING TO
RESET THAT FOR HER SHE PLACES
ON USER COLD ONE MOMENT. GIVE
IT A QUICK MOMENT HERE. BECAUSE
OF AN- OKAY LET'S DO THAT-
HOWEVER CAN WE GO TO JUST JUST
STANDARD PUBLIC COMMENT IN
SUPPORT AND THEY WILL COME BACK
TO ME AS WE WERE IF WE- IF WE
CAN SORT OF OUR TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTIES. HI I'M- JIM.
THERE YOU ARE AND YOU HEAR ME
NOW YES. THANK YOU SO MUCH-
SHARON WEAVER WITH THE SAN
JOAQUIN RIVER PARKWAY AND
CONSERVATION TRUST AND I JUST
WANNA THANK- ASSEMBLY MEMBER DR
JOAQUIN ARAMBULA FOR ALTERING
THIS IMPORTANT BILL WE THINK
THESE ARE MUCH NEEDED CHANGES
TO THE CONSERVANCY BOARD- WE
ARE EXCITED ABOUT THE ADDITION
OF NEW MEMBERS THE CHANGES AND
TO ELIMINATE THE NEED FOR A.
RIVER BOTTOM LANDOWNER MEMBER
WHICH IS ST OSITION THAT IT'S
BECOME HARDER AND HARDER TO
FILL. OVER THE YEARS AT THE
CONSERVANCY HAS ACQUIRED MORE
LAND ALONG THE RIVER. AND WE'RE
ALSO EXCITED ABOUT THE CHANGES
TO THE CHAIRMANSHIP AND HOW IT
ROTATES ON. THE VARIOUS MEMBERS
OF THE CONSERVANCY BOARD WE
THINK ALL OF THESE CHANGES ARE
WELL OVERDUE AND MUCH NEEDED.
AND AGAIN WE OFFER OUR FULL
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL AND THANK
YOU FOR CONSIDERING IT TODAY.%
OKAY THANK YOU SO MUCH I'M-
MANY ARE THE LEADING WITNESSES
AND- OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OF THE ROOM SEEING ON HERE OR
IN THE ALTERNATIVE ROOM NONE I
COULD GO TO LINES. OPERATOR IF
ANYONE WAS JUST WHICH IS
TESTIFYING TO SUPPORT. YES IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
AB FIVE FIVE NINE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME WE
DO ALREADY HAVE EIGHT IN Q. WE
WILL START WITH LINE NUMBER.
EIGHTY EIGHT ZERO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. ONCE ARAMBULA THE
CALIFORNIA NEEDED CONSERVATION
VOTERS IN STRONG SUPPORT EIGHTY
FIVE FIVE NINE. THANK YOU NEXT
OVER THE LINE NUMBER NINETY ONE
THAT'S NINE ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI GOOD MORNING THIS IS
LISTED ADDRESS TO ME- WITH.
LEAGUE OF. CONSERVATION
MOTORIST IN STRONG SUPPORT OF.
WE'LL TAKE A STRONG SUPPORT IT
SO THE SENATE. NEXT. RIGHT WILL
LIGHT NUMBER FIFTY ONE THAT'S
FIVE ONE. GOOD MORNING DANIEL
BROWN OF THE HATCHING CARE CLUB
CALIFORNIA AND DEPORT ALSO
REGISTERING SUPPORT FOR
DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE AND
CALIFORNIA NATIVE PLANT SOCIETY
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH.
MIXED WITH A LINE NUMBER EIGHTY
NINE THAT'S EIGHT NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
KIMBERLY MCLEAN FRESNO BUILDING
HEALTHY COMMUNITIES AND STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB FIVE FIVE NINE
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY. NEXT THIS IS MIXES
LINE NUMBER EIGHTY EIGHT EIGHT
EIGHT ONE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
VETERANS AFFAIRS BUILDING. AND
IT THE CARD EIGHT I THANK.
THANK YOU. A LINE NUMBER
SEVENTY NINE THAT'S NINE LINES
OF. GOOD MORNING EVERYONE. AND
PRESIDENT OF THE HAPPY
COMMUNITY. EIGHTY FIVE I THANK.
THANK YOU. GOOGLE LINE NUMBER
NINETY NINE THAT'S NINE NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO BUT
LOOK AROUND MOST IN SUPPORT
WITH FRESNO BUILDING HEALTHY
COMMUNITIES IN SUPPORT OF AB
FIVE FIVE NINE. THANK YOU AND
WE'LL ONE MORE IN Q. WE'LL GO
TO LINE NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
TWO THAT'S ONE ZERO TWO. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS GINA
SANTIAGO NOT STRONGLY SUPPORT
OF AB FIVE FIVE NINE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. AND MR KERIO VALLEY
EXHAUSTED THE QUEUE AT THIS
TIME. OKAY- LET'S TURN TO
OPPOSITION- WE DO NOT HAVE ANY
LEAD OPPOSITION TO ANY IN THE
HEARING ROOM OR IN THE
ALTERNATIVE ROOM WILL GO TO THE
LINE'S OPERATOR AND- OPPOSITION
ON THE LINES. IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO AB FIVE
FIVE NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
BEEN IN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE
DO CURRENTLY HAVE ONE IN Q. AND
THAT'S LINE NUMBER FORTY FOUR.
FOUR FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
POLICY OWNER ON BEHALF OF THE
MADERA AND FRESNO COUNTY
SUPERVISORS BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS STILL OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY ANY OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION. NO ONE ELSE WE
QUEUED UP AT THIS TIME MISTER
CHAIR OKAY VERY GOOD WILL BRING
IT BACK TO DYESS- CENTER LAYER
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIR- LET ME COMMEND THE
AUTHOR FOR THIS BILL THIS. IS
YOU CAN TELL FROM THE ANALYSIS
I SERVED ON THIS CONSERVANCY
BOARD FOR EIGHT YEARS AND THERE
BEEN SOME CONTENTIOUS ISSUES
AND SOME ISSUES ABOUT
REPRESENTATION WHICH YOU ARE
ADDRESSING WITH THIS BILL. IN
THERE'S ALWAYS BEEN ONE KEY
THING ABOUT GOVERNMENTS FOR
CONSERVANCY SWITCHES. FROM THE
STATE SIDE TO TRY TO HAVE AT
LEAST ONE MORE MEMBER.
APPOINTED BY STATE OFFICIALS
THAT LOCAL AS IT'S A STATE
AGENCY AT THIS BILL HONOR
STATUS WITHIN THE EXPANSION SO
IT'S GOOD THE ONE QUESTION I
HAD IS A TRIBAL REPRESENTATIVE
HE SAID BY THIS BILL THAT IS A
GOOD THING AND- AS I UNDERSTAND
IT THERE'S FOUR DIFFERENT
TRIBES THAT MIGHT BE IN THE
REGION THAT WOULD QUALIFY FOR
MEMBERSHIP. AND IT JUST SAYS
THE GOVERNOR WILL CHOOSE FROM A
LIST. AND I'M WONDERING. HE
THAT PUTS THE GOVERNOR IN A
ROUGH BEHIND AND TO SOMEBODY
GETS APPOINTED FROM ONE TRIBE
AT THE NOT TRUCK JUST GETS TO
REPRESENTATION FOR A LONG TIME
AND THERE'S NO ROTATION. I
DON'T KNOW WHAT THE ANSWER TO
MY QUESTION IS BUT I'M
WONDERING IF THERE IS A BETTER
WAY TO ENSURE A ROTATION OR- OR
SOME PARTICIPATION AMONG THE
DIFFERENT TRIBES AND I DON'T
KNOW IF IT'S A FIXED TERM
INVENTED. DEFAULTS TO SOMEBODY
ELSE OR OR WHATEVER HAVE YOU
GIVEN THOUGHT TO THAT ISSUE AND
HOW YOU'RE DOING THIS BILL.
FIRST THE THANK YOU SENATOR FOR
THE QUESTION AND I DO BELIEVE
IT'S- FIVE TOTAL TRIBAL BALCONY
NINETY THAT WE HAVE IDENTIFIED
BETWEEN FRESNO AND MADERA
COUNTY. AND DO THINK IT IS
NECESSARY FOR US TO HAVE
TRANSITIONS BETWEEN THE
REPRESENTATIONS BETWEEN THE
TRIBAL NATIONS. BUT WOULD LIKE
THE ORIGINAL STEWARDS OF THE
LAND STYLE ALSO HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SHAPE WHAT THE
RIVER LOOKS LIKE. AND WITHOUT
PUTTING A SPECIFIC TERM ON IT
WOULD HOPE THAT THE TRIBAL
NATIONS WOULD SEE THIS. SEAT AS
AN OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE
EDUCATION ABOUT. WHAT OCCURRED
ON THEIR NATIVE LAND SO LONG
BEFORE THE CONSERVANCY BEGAN.
OKAY I UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO DO BUT- THAT JUST
HAPPENED GIVE IT SOME THOUGHT
BECAUSE THEN THEY'LL BE A BILL
BACK IN FRONT OF THE SINCE SIX
YEARS BECAUSE IT'S BEEN ONE
TRIBE THE OTHERS HAVE SCREAMED.
AND SCREAMED OUT EVERYBODY'S
CRAZED ABOUT IT AND SO JUST
GIVE IT SOME THOUGHT AS YOU
MOVE THE BILL ON MY PROJECT.
ARE YOUR ENTIRE EFFORT I LOOK
FORWARD TO SUPPORTING THE BILL.
GOOD THANK YOU CENTER LAYERED
AND THAT THE VICE CHAIR DID ASK
ME IF ANY COULD BE IN OUR IN
YOUR CLOTHES BUT JUST TO
RESPOND TO SOME OF THE CONCERNS
RAISED BY THE OPPOSITION- BUT I
WOULD SAY. YOU KNOW YOU'RE
YOU'RE YOU'RE FRAMEWORK HERE I
THINK MAKES A LOT OF SENSE. I'M
PARTICULARLY SAID ABOUT THE
YOUTH MEMBER. JOINING I THINK
YOUNG PEOPLE. HAVE A DIFFERENT
APPROACH MAY BE TO ISSUES LIKE
ACCESS AND EQUITY IN A LOT FOR
THE COMMUNITY I THINK. THAT
KIND OF LOCAL VOICE EVEN IF IT
IS COMING FROM SOME KIND OF.
STATE APPOINTMENT. I STILL.
THINK WE'LL LIFT- THE COMMUNITY
VOICES OVER THAT YOU'RE TRYING
TO ELEVATE HERE SO- I DON'T
SEE. THAT APPOINTMENT PROCESS
IS NEGATING THE LOCAL IMPACT-
OR- AGENCY THAT THAT THEY WOULD
HAVE IN THAT SO APPRECIATE YOU
WORKING WITH US ON THIS
LEGISLATION- IF THERE ARE NO
OTHER. QUESTIONS SENTENCE
CENTER EGGMAN. THANK YOU THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THIS. FORWARD
AND LOOKING OUT FOR YOUR AREA
LIKE THIS- AND I AND I HEARD A
LOT OF TALK ABOUT- THAT THAT
THAT DIVERSITY WHICH IS
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT BUT I
DON'T HEAR MUCH ABOUT GENDER. I
JUST WANT TO KNOW- AND I DON'T
KNOW THAT THE CURRENT
COMPOSITION OF THE BOARD BUT IF
THERE'S GENDER REPRESENTATION
AS WELL. AND IF THAT WILL ALSO
BE SOME CONSIDERATIONS WOULD
LOOK AT. I'M HAPPY TO GET THE
INFORMATION BACK TO YOU AND-
WILL CONTINUE- THOSE
CONVERSATIONS. THANK YOU CENTER
EGGMAN CENTER JONES. THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN STAR CINEMA ROMULAN
AND MAYBE VERY I DO APOLOGIZE
FOR HAVING RUN OUT REAL QUICK
AND SERVICE RECORD DOWN IN-
INSURANCE THERE'S SEEMS TO BE
SOME DISCUSSION ON- IN A WORD
THIS CONSERVANCY'S LOCATED AND-
MY UNDERSTANDING IS IT'S NOT
IT'S NOT IN YOUR DISTRICT IS
THAT CORRECT. THIS IS A
REGIONAL AMENITY FOR THE ENTIRE
SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY THE SAN
JOAQUIN RIVER AS THE SECOND
LARGEST RIVER WEEK LONGEST
RIVER THAT WE HAVE IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA MUCH OF THE RIVER
DOES RUN THROUGH MY DESKTOP
OKAY. THERE GREAT THANK YOU FOR
CLARIFYING THAT AND THEN
THERE'S ALSO TWO LETTERS OF
OPPOSITION FROM THE DIFFERENT
COUNTIES. THAT ARE THAT THE
CONSERVANCY RUNS IN AND- I WAS
WONDERING IF YOU HAD SOME
COMMENTS YOU KNOW I'M I'M SURE
YOU'RE FAMILIAR WITH THEIR-
OPPOSITION I CAN READ INTO IF
YOU LIKE BUT I JUST WANTED TO.
HAVE THAT OTHER MEMBERS CALL ME
AND ASK ME TO. IMPAIR PAY
ATTENTION THAT SO I JUST WANT
TO SEE IF YOU HAVE SOME
COMMENTS REGARDING. WELL THE
COUNTIES REMAIN OPPOSED TO THE
MEASURE THAT'S BEFORE US I
WOULD POINT TO THE RESOLUTIONS
THAT WERE PASSED BY BOTH THE
CITIES. OF FRESNO AND MADERA AS
WELL AS THE TESTIMONY WE HEARD
TODAY FROM THE MAYOR OF MADERA.
THE PEOPLE OF MY COMMUNITY ARE
ASKING FOR MORE PARK SPACE AS
EVIDENCED BY A RECENT.
PROPOSITION THAT WAS PASSED BY
THE VOTERS IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
IN FRESNO COUNTY. THAT WAS LED
BY THE YOUTH WHO WE ARE NOW
HIGHLIGHTING AND- PLACING A
SEAT ON TO THIS CONSERVANCY
BOARD. AND DO BELIEVE THAT THE
PEOPLE OF MY COMMUNITY ARE
ASKING FOR INCREASED PARKS
PLACE. OKAY THANK YOU- SEE NO
OTHER COMMENTS I WOULD.
ENTERTAIN A MOTION AT THIS
POINT. THE MOTION FROM CENTER
EGGMAN- SOME MEMBER WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AND I VOTING APPRECIATE ALL THE
WORK WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO DO
COLLABORATIVELY THANK YOU- THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
BUT FIRST AMEND AND RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
SHE CAN SO WOULD YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. FILE ITEM THREE
AB FIVE FIVE NINE MOTIONS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS STERN.
HI ALL RIGHT JONES. JONES NO
ALLEN. ALLEN HI EGGMAN. EGGMAN
ONLINE GROWTH HERTZBERG. HUESO
LAYERED HI LARRY HI LIMóN.
THAT MEASURE HAS FOUR VOTES
WILL LEAVE IT ON CALL FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU- WE
HAVE ANOTHER AUTHOR RIGHT IN
TIME TO DO CONSENT AND MAYES
BEFORE I. CHECKED ON THE
INSURANCE DESERVE WRAP UP OKAY.
ARE YOU WANTED TO OPEN THE
RULES ON THOSE ITEMS. YES
THAT'S RIGHT ALRIGHT MISTER-
JUST BEAR WITH US ONE SECOND WE
OPEN THE ROLE ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. THE CONSENT CALENDAR
IS CURRENT VOTE IS FOUR ZERO
JONES. THE CONCESSION HONORED
BY JONES HI GROVE HERTZBERG
HUESO LIMóN. OKAY WITH THE
MEASURE ON CALL- FELL INTO A
BEFORE FOR TO CLEAN UP IN THE
ROLE. OKAY YOUR HONOR. OKAY
THANK YOU SEE A MEMBER FOR THE
INDULGENCE FILE ITEM FIVE AB
EIGHT NINE SIX PLEASE PROCEED
WORK IN THE COMMUNITY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR APPRECIATE IT
MEMBERS UP I WANT TO THANK THE
CHAIR AND THE COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR- WORKING ON THIS BILL WITH
US AND WE- I. APPRECIATE THE
AMENDMENTS THAT ARE ACCEPTING
ALL OF THE AMENDMENTS- ON PAGE
SEVEN OF THE ANALYSIS. UP THERE
ARE OVER FOUR THOUSAND- IDLE
WELLS THAT HAVEN'T PAID I DON'T
WILL FILL THE CAT I DON'T WELL
FEES. AND THAT ARE NOT IN A
WELL MANAGEMENT PROGRAM- RESULT
IN OVER SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS
OVER TO THE STATE- MANY OF
THESE ARE IN MY DISTRICT BUT
THEY ARE SPREAD. AROUND TO IT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA- MANY
OF THEM ARE WORTH AND WELLS AND
THOSE ARE WELL SHOULD HAVE BEEN
LEFT UNPLUG. AND CONTINUE TO
LEAK GAS HAVE NO OPERATOR
MONITORING THEM- CREATING
ENORMOUS LIABILITY FOR THE
STATE SO- BABIES EIGHT NINETY
SIX SIMPLY PROVIDE THE STATE
WITH ANOTHER MECHANISM TO BE
ABLE TO- TRY TO RECOVER THESE
COSTS. AND HELP AVOID US STATE
TAXPAYERS BEING STUCK WITH THE
LIABILITY OF THESE SO WITH ME
TO TESTIFY TODAY IS NIKITA
KARANA FROM THE NATIONAL ASIAN
RESOURCE DEFENSE. COUNCIL AND
OVER THE PHONE IS LINDA CROP ON
BEHALF OF THE ENVIRONMENT
WITHIN CENTER. THE YOU SOMEONE-
MISS KARATE DO YOU WANT TO. GET
STARTED FOR US HERE ON THE
LINES. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE TO
KEEP THE KARATE WITH THE
NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL ENERGY PLEASE WITH THE
COURT EIGHTY EIGHT NINETY SIX.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BENNETT FOR HIS
WORK ON THE SPELL EFFORT
LEADERSHIP ON CLIMATE ACTION
MORE BROADLY I THINK HER
THEY'RE CURRENTLY THOUSAND THE
VITAL OIL AND GAS WELLS IN
CALIFORNIA THEN YOU PUT YOUR
CARD ON. YOUR I HAVE NOT BEEN
PROPERLY DECOMMISSIONED WE
NEEDED I DON'T ORSON WELLES HOW
SIGNIFICANT RISK AIR QUALITY
DRINKING WATER AND HELP THE
FRONTLINE COMMUNITIES WHO LIVE
AND WORK NEAR THE FACILITY IS.
WORKING WELL BUT NO BIPOLAR
INVOLVED OPERATORS ALL THE
TITLE TAXPAYERS WITH THE
COPPERS WITH INCREASED COST
BURDEN POTENTIALLY IN THE
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS. AND THEN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN CEST REPORT
POINTED OUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE NATION'S
FOURTH LARGEST PRODUCER OF
CRUDE OIL AND FIFTEENTH OF
NATURAL GAS AT THE MASSIVE
FINANCIAL LIABILITY PROBLEM ON
ITS HANDS THAT THE ISSUE GOES
UNADDRESSED. EIGHTY EIGHT
NINETY SIX OF THE COMMONSENSE
MEASURE THAT PROVIDES THE STATE
WITH ADDITIONAL AUTHORITY AND
SOME OF THE NECESSARY TOOLS TO
BOTH HOLD NON COMPLIANT
IDYLLWILD OPERATORS ACCOUNTABLE
AS WELL AS ENCOURAGE COMPANIES
TO WORK WITH THE STATE AND
BECOME COMPLIANT WITH EXISTING
LAW FOR THESE REASONS I DON'T
IF YOU PRACTICE SUPPORT EIGHTY
EIGHT NINETY SIX TODAY AND WE
ARE DRY ABOUT. THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO TALK TO
THANK. YOU BURMA'S CROP WELCOME.
GOOD MORNING STERN INCOME
MEMBERS MY NAME LINDA BECAUSE-
CHIEF COUNSEL AT THE END BY.
DEFENSE CENTER OF PUBLIC
INTEREST LAW FIRM. CHECKS IN
FARM. GEN BARBARA. JEALOUS BY.
CAL EACH ET C. SUPPORTS AB
NINETY. OVER THE PAST FIVE
YEARS APPROXIMATELY TWO HUNDRED
FORTY EIGHT OIL AND GAS
PRODUCER'S WITH MORE THAN A
HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE BILLION IN
DEBT ENTERED INTO BANKRUPTCY.
BUT TWENTY EIGHTEEN REPORT
ESTIMATED THAT THE TOTAL COST
TO PLUG ALL ACTIVE IN IDYLLWILD
TO CALIFORNIA WOULD BE ABOUT
NINE BILLION DOLLARS. THIS BILL
PROVIDES CAL JAM WITH THE TOOLS
TO PROTECT THE ENVIRONMENT
PUBLIC HEALTH AND TAXPAYERS.
FIRST THE BUILDING AUTHORITY
WOULD GET CAL JIM HUTTON
PRIORITY FOR REPAYMENT IN THE.
EVENT AN OPERATOR FILED FOR
BANKRUPTCY. SECOND THE BILL
WOULD. A YEAR TO CALL UNPAID
IDLE WEALTHY. IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN ALONE NINE HUNDRED
FIFTY SEVEN OPERATORS FAILED TO
PAY FEES OVER TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED WELLS. IS TO PROVIDE A
MECHANISM TO ADDRESS THE
GROWING NUMBER OF UNPAID FEES.
FINALLY THE BUILDING AUTHORITY
MAY ALSO BE USED TO REMEDIATE
UNSAFE WELL THAT THREATEN CLEAN
AIR WATER AND HEALTHY
COMMUNITIES. OIL WELLS ARE
KNOWN TO EMIT TOXIC EMISSIONS
METHANE AND PLAYMOBIL GASES
INCLUDING LIKELY CARCINOGENS
LIKE BENZENE. MORE THAN TREANOR
FIFTY THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS
LIVE WITHIN SIX HUNDRED FEET OF
UNPLUGGED WELLS. LAST NEXT
BLACK AND LOW INCOME PEOPLE
BEING DISPROPORTIONATELY AT
RISK. HARPER LEE MAINTAIN WELL
CASINGS CAN ALSO TRYING
GROUNDWATER IN FRESH WATER
AQUIFERS. EACH REGION EDC THIS
COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT AB EIGHT
NINETY SIX. THANK YOU MISS
CRAWFORD I WILL NOT TURN TO-
GENERAL SUPPORT- ANY IN THE
HEARING ROOM. SEEING NONE ARE
IN THE ALTERNATE ROOMS NONE
TRUNKLINES. IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU BEIJING JAN IF YOUR SUPPORT
OF AB EIGHT NINETY SIX PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. WHEN I
GO TO LINE NUMBER EIGHTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MARTIN O'MALLEY THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXAVAR LINE NUMBER FIFTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. DANIEL BROWN
ON BEHALF OF SIERRA CLUB
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. AN EXTRA LINE NUMBER
FIFTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. DR
WILLIAM PATRICK SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF CLIMATE HELP NOW THE
COALITION OF FIVE HUNDRED
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB EIGHT NINE SIX THANK YOU
THANK YOU. NEXT TO A LINE
NUMBER SIXTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS IT SAYS IGOR
TRACKER VICE CHAIR OF THE
ALAMEDA COUNTY DEMOCRATIC PARTY
AND CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEMOCRATIC PARTY ENVIRONMENTAL.
CHRIS AND ENTHUSIASTIC SUPPORT
ON BOTH COUNTS THANK YOU THANK
YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU WHAT A
LINE NUMBER NINETY TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. IN LINE BY NINETY TWO
IS ROUTE ONE CAN IF YOUR
SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT NINETY SIX
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN JAIL AT
THIS TIME. BORDERLINE NUMBER
NINETY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THIS IS CHANDU TRICKS ON
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
INDIVISIBLE CALIFORNIA GREEN
CHAIN. THREE FIFTY BAY AREA
ACTION THREE FIFTY SOUTH BAY L.
A. FIFTY VENTURA COUNTY CRIME
LAB AND- THE NEWLY FORMED ST
FIFTY SOUTH SIDE BUDGET STATE
OF ALLIANCE BANKING ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BENNETT I'M IN FULL
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. BANNISTER
SURE PERSON AT THIS TIME WE
HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN Q. VERY
GOOD- WILL TURN OUT TO
OPPOSITION DO WE HAVE ANY
OPPOSITION LET'S SEE. THE KNOW
THE OPPOSITION NOTED ON FILE SO
JUST TURN THE HEARING ROOM
SEEING ON HERE OR IN THE
ALTERNATE ALTERNATE ROOM NONE.
BUT IT TURNED OF THE PHONE
LINES ANYONE WISHING TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION TO AB. EIGHT NINE
SIX. THANK YOU IF YOU'RE
OPPOSITION AB EIGHT NINE SIX
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. ONE CANNOT
OPPOSITION AB EIGHT NINE SIX
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. WE JUST ANOTHER
MOMENT. JUST ONE MORE MOMENT.
WHERE TO GO TO LINE NUMBER ONE
ZERO NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THIS IS BACK WHERE YOUNG- WITH
WESTERN STATES PETROLEUM
ASSOCIATION WANTED THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR WORKING WITH US
EARLY ON THIS BILL WE ARE
NEUTRAL AND YOU TO BE NEUTRAL.
WHAT ARE YOUR LINE NUMBER ONE
FIFTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M
CATHERINE DOESN'T THE ALLIANCE
IN NURSING OR HEALTHY
ENVIRONMENTS AND I COULDN'T GET
IN ON THE SUPPORT THAT WE
ENTHUSIASTICALLY SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU WILL NOT YOUR
SUPPORT THANK. NUMBER ONE
NUMBER ONE FOURTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ONE ONE FOURTEEN IS
DROPPED AT THIS TIME MISTER
PERSON WE HAVE NOBODY ELSE IN
Q. OKAY. THANK YOU- SO NO
FURTHER OPPOSITION WILL BRING
IT BACK TO THE MEMBERS ON THE
DíAS ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
GOT A CENTER LAYERED JUST A
QUICK ONE THAT'S TANGENTIALLY
RELATED BECAUSE THIS IS A GREAT
BILL IN A STRONGLY SUPPORTED.
OF THE ANALYSIS TALKS ABOUT FOR
REPORTS THAT ARE OVERDUE FROM
THE AGENCIES AND I WONDERED IF
THE COMMITTEE TAKES ANY ACTION
OR REFERS TO THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE BUT WHAT WE DO TO
MAKE SURE THAT REPORTS ARE
FORGIVEN US FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION ON THESE ISSUES.
WE'VE WE ACTUALLY IN LIEU OF AN
OVERSIGHT HEARING DURING OUR
VERY COMPRESSED HEARINGS
EARLIER THIS YEAR- WE SENT A
LETTER INTO THE ADMINISTRATION.
I BELIEVE THAT WAS IN. MARCH
LISTING ALL THE ITEMS
OUTSTANDING SO FAR THEY'VE
THEY'VE SENT US BACK THERE I TO
WILL REPORTS THEY'VE HIT ONE
BUT THEY'VE GOT TWO OR THREE
OTHER CRUCIAL REPORTS
OUTSTANDING AS WELL AS A LOT OF
THIS WORK. I WAS TOLD BY THE
SECRETARY THAT THAT LETTER IS
COMING BACK DETAILING- THE
TIMELINE- IMMINENTLY BUT- I
PROJECT INITIATIVE IMMINENCE I
THINK YOU'RE RIGHT TO RAISE.
THE OVERSIGHT ROLE THE BUDGET
LETTERMAN WEREN'T JULY I DON'T
KNOW WHAT EMINENT MEANS BUT THE
DISTRIBUTORS RESPONSE TO THE
COMMITTEE. MEMBERS BECAUSE
UNDER YOURS WOULD BE. IMPORTANT
FOR AND TO SENATOR Y. CASKEY IS
CHAIR OF THE BUDGET SUB
COMMITTEE- I THINK WE IT WOULD
REALLY BENEFIT US IN THE
DISCUSSION OF THIS BILL TO HAVE
THOSE REPORTS AND SO ARE THAT
WOULD BE A GOOD THING TO DO.
THANK YOU MISTER SHARP THANK
YOU A ACTION TO COMMIT NO I
APPRECIATE CENTER AND- YOU
KNOW. THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAY
BE NEW TO SACRAMENTO CERTAINLY
NOT NEW TO THE OIL AND GAS
REGULATION AND HAS BEEN ON THE
FRONT LINES FOR A WHILE AND-
VENTURA. COUNTY AND SANTA
BARBARA COUNTY NOW- BUT I WOULD
I WOULD JUST SAY IS THAT WE
SHOULDN'T HAVE TO DO HAVE
LEGISLATION TO DO THIS WORK A
LOT OF THAT SHOULD BE HAPPENING
AND- SO YOU KNOW THESE THIS IS.
A LESS EFFICIENT WAY
POTENTIALLY TO GET IT ALTHOUGH
I WOULD SAY THAT THERE'S SOME
USEFUL TOOLS PROVIDED HERE BY
THE AUTHOR WHEN IT COMES TO
LEAD AUTHORITY AND ALSO
ESTABLISHING THIS COLLECTIONS
UNIT. I THINK IT'SA REALLY
WISE APPROACH TO SORT OF
FORMALIZE THAT BUT THERE'S NO
REPLACEMENT FOR JUST THROUGHPUT
I'M I WOULD NOTE THOUGH- YOU
KNOW APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S
WORK OF THE COMMITTEE AND
TAKING THIS ON- IT. THE DELAYS
IN DERIVING AT THAT
DETERMINATION. OF- I. OF THAT
WELL AS ACTUALLY DOES AND GO
THROUGH THAT TYPE SEARCH NOT
JUST IDOL WELL. COLLECTIONS BUT
THE ACTUAL TITLE SEARCH HAS
PROVEN TO BE A VERY BELEAGUERED
AND DELAYED PROCESS THAT
ACTUALLY IS PRESSING FOR
INDUSTRY. FOR ENVIRONMENTAL
COMMUNITY FOR MANY INVOLVED AND
SO. YOU KNOW WE THINK THIS BILL
IS GOING TO MOVE THAT FORWARD
BUT THE AUTHOR AND I WOULD. BE
SOLID UNDERSTANDING THAT
THERE'S IF THERE'S MORE WORK WE
NEED TO BE DOING. A TO PUSH
THAT ALONG OR FREE UP CAL JIM.
DOING A TITLE SURGERY AT A
COUNTY RECORD OFFICE ALL IN A
HOUSE AND WAITING FOR THAT.
PROCESS TO TAKE A YEAR OR TWO
IS SIMPLY NOT GOING TO WORK AS
A TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
PROPOSAL FOR WELL REMEDIATION
IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. IF
WE'RE GONNA ACTUALLY SPEND THAT
MONEY DOWN- WE'VE GOT TO HAVE
SOME THROUGHPUT SO APPRECIATE
YOU. DOING THIS STRUCTURE WORK
HERE TO GET THAT DONE AND- LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YU
GOING FORWARD. TO GET SOME
OUTCOMES WELL BY WELL HERE YOU
KNOW IT'S NOT GOING TO GET
SOLVED OVERNIGHT BUT WE GOT TO
CHIP AWAY WELL BY WELL. THAT
AND ALLOW YOU TO- CLOSE IN WAS
THERE ANY OTHER FURTHER
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR. SHARING I
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU ALSO ON. FURTHER EFFORTS TO
GET AFTER THIS AND I RECOGNIZE
THIS BILL BY ITSELF DOESN'T
CLOSE ALL OF THE- A WORKER OR
COVER ALL OF THE WORK IT NEEDS
TO BE DONE- THERE IS NO
SUBSTITUTE FOR JUST HAVING
GREAT PROFESSIONAL WORK BEING
DONE BY CAL JONES- ON THIS.
INCLUDING TURNING AND REPORTS
ON TIME- KICKS CENTER- IT'S
TIME IT'S APPROPRIATE TO YOU
BRING THAT UP BECAUSE THE
AMENDMENTS TO THIS BILL HAVE
BEEN ADDED- CALL FOR REPORTS
BACK FROM CAL JAM SO. IF WE'RE
NOT GETTING THE CURRENT
REPORTS- I THINK IT'S GOOD FOR
US TO POINT THAT OUT. TO MAKE
SURE WE GET THESE REPORTS ALSO-
IN A TIMELY MANNER. AND WITH
THAT- I REALLY APPRECIATE THE
SUPPORT OF THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL AND
THE ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE
CENTER AND- THE TESTIMONY OF-
MISS GRANDE AND- THIS- HOUSE-
MISS CROP. FROM CINNABAR AND
WITH THAT ASKED RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
SO MUCH OF MOTION FROM CENTER
LAYERED AND THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED BUT FIRST
AMENDED WE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
CHIEF CAN SOMEONE PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. FILE ITEM FIVE AB
EIGHT NINE SIX MOTIONS DO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS STERN- EARN
ALL RIGHT JONES. JONES ALLEN.
ALLEN I EGGMAN. EGGMAN RA
GROWTH HERTZBERG FIVE BIRCH
BURKE ALL RIGHT HUESO. LEARNED
ON LITTERED ALL RIGHT LIMóN.
THAT MEASURES FIVE VOTES- WE
WILL LEAVE IT ON CALL FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU SO
MUCH ASSEMBLY MEMBER THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- SEREMOS WELCOME.
FIVE AND SIX. MEMBERS THIS IS
AB EIGHT. ELEVEN EIGHTY THREE.
WELCOME THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN SENATORS- FIRST
OF ALL I WANTED KNOWLEDGE AND I
WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEES TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS-
I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN EIGHTY
THREE. THIS BILL WOULD CREATE A
PROGRAM WITHIN THE WILDLIFE
CONSERVATION BOARD. TO PROVIDE
FUNDING FOR PROJECTS IN THE
CALIFORNIA DESERT TO ADDRESS
THE IMPACTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE
TO PROTECT AND RESTORE DESERT
HABITAT AND SACRED ANCESTRAL
LANDS OF LOCAL NATIVE AMERICAN
PEOPLE. THIS ALSO PROVIDES
PUBLIC ACCESS OR RECREATIONAL
AMENITIES AND REDUCES THE
THREATS OF WILDFIRE DROUGHT
FLOODS AND OTHER CONTRASTS
CATASTROPHE EVENTS. THE
CALIFORNIA DESERT'S MERIT
INCREASE PUBLIC ATTENTION AND
INVESTMENT THE DESERT REGION IS
HOME TO THE LARGEST STILL
INTACT ECOSYSTEM IN THE
CONTINUOUS UNITED STATES. THESE
LAST PERFORM CRITICAL
ENVIRONMENTAL ROLES INCLUDING
CAPTURING AND STORING CARBON TO
HELP US FIGHT THE CLIMATE
CHANGE CRISIS. THE DESERT
REGION IS ALSO THE HOMELAND OF
NUMEROUS TRAVEL COMMUNITIES IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WHO
HAVE RESIDED THERE SINCE TIME
IMMEMORIAL. AND WHO HAVE ALSO
BEEN WILL ALSO BENEFIT FROM THE
DESERT CONSERVATION PROGRAM.
THAT'S COUNTY SUPERVISORS AREA
COUNTY THE LARGEST COUNTY IN
THE STATE I WORK TO PROTECT AN
AREA KNOWN IN JOSHUA TREE AS
COYOTE WHOLE ASIDE DIDN'T
PEOPLE KNEW ABOUT FOR YEARS
THAT HAD PACTO AND PICTOGRAPHS
ALL IN THE CANYON THAT'S THEIR
WITHIN THE COUNTY HOLE. AND
THAT WAS IN THE FLOOD CONTROL
AREA OF THE COUNTY AND I WORK
DAN WITH THE CALIFORNIA INDIAN
LANDS CONSERVANCY TO GET THAT
PROPERTY DEEDED OVER FOR PROPER
PROTECTION. THAT'S SO IMPORTANT
AND VITAL THIS BILL IS IN
PROTECTING OUR AREAS IN THE
DESERT. AB ELEVEN EIGHTY THREE
WILL ASSIST IN SUPPORTING THE
PROTECTION OF THESE KINDS OF
SITES AND MANY OTHERS.
UNFORTUNATELY CALIFORNIA FUNDED
INITIATIVES INCLUDING PASSED
BONDS HAVE INVESTED FAR LESS
CONSERVATION FUNDING INTO THE
DESERT THAN OTHER AREAS OF
CALIFORNIA PARTICULARLY THOSE
REGIONS WITH EXISTING STATE.
CUTS SERVICE CONSERVANCIES. AB
ELEVEN EIGHTY THREE PROVIDES A
SOLUTION TO THIS PROBLEM. BY
CREATING A PROGRAM WITH THE WCB
FOCUSED ON FUNDING IMPORTANT
PROJECTS WITHIN THIS REGION.
IT'LL WORK WITH NGOS CALIFORNIA
TRIBES LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
RESOURCE CONSERVATION DISTRICTS
AND OTHERS. WHO ARE NOW HAVE A
SPECIFIC PROGRAM FOR THE MANY
IMPORTANT CONSERVATION
RECREATION AND PUBLIC
EDUCATION. THAT NEEDS TO HAPPEN
WITHIN THE DESERT'S IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. WITH ME
TODAY TO DISCUSS THE IMPORTANT
BUILT HIS GARY HAHN EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE MOJAVE DESERT
LAND TRUST AMBER INTEGRALES
FROM THE CONSERVATION HISPANIC
ACCESS FOUNDATION. THANKS SO
MUCH FOR YOUR PRESENTATION
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LET'S TURN TO
LINES- MISTER HAN MISS GAY GOES.
THIS SPEAKING CHAIRMAN STERN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY
IN SUPPORT OF AB ELEVEN EIGHTY
THREE I AM EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE MOJAVE DESERT LAND TRUST
WERE DEDICATED TO THE
PROTECTION OF THE MOJAVE AND
COLORADO DESERT OUR SERVICE
SHARING SPANS MORE THAN TWENTY
SIX MILLION ACRES WE COMPANIES
OUR MISSION THROUGH LAND
ACQUISITION AND MANAGEMENT
OUTREACH AND PUBLIC POLICY WORK
TODAY WE HAVE CONSERVE MORE
THAN ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND ACRES
AS THE FORMER ASSOCIATE
DIRECTOR OF THE COACHELLA
VALLEY MOUNTAINS CONSERVANCY
EXPERIENCE FIRST HAND THE
BENEFITS OF A FOCUS DESERT
CONSERVATION PROGRAM. SINCE ITS
INCEPTION MORE THAN SIXTY EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS HAVE BEEN
DIRECTED TO THE COACHELLA
VALLEY TO CONSERVE ITS NATURAL
LANDSCAPES AND TO PROVIDE TO
THE PUBLIC ACTIONS THE
CALIFORNIA DESERT CONSERVATION
PROGRAM WOULD EXTEND THE SAME
BENEFIT TO THE REST OF THE
DESERT THE MUCH LARGER AREA
WITH MANY CONSERVATION BE
CALIFORNIA'S DESERT STORM
WORLDWIDE SIGNIFICANCE WITH
THEIR VAST AND VARIED
LANDSCAPES AND RICH BIOLOGICAL
DIVERSITY ICONIC SPECIES SUCH
AS DESERT TORTOISES BIGHORN
SHEEP AND WESTERN JOSHUA TREE
ART NUMBER MATIC OF THIS
DIVERSITY. THE DESERT'S ARE
ALSO RICH IN CULTURAL HISTORY
AND ALSO GREAT IMPORTANCE TO
INDIGENOUS PEOPLES THERE ARE
POPULAR AND GROWING OUTDOOR
RECREATION DESTINATION AND
TOURISM IS THE ECONOMIC ENGINE
OF MANY DOES OUR COMMUNITY WELL
ACTUALLY THEY ARE A CARBON SINK
HOPING TO FIGHT CLIMATE CHANGE
SHOULD THEY ARE DOESN'T FACE
MANY THREATS INCLUDING CLIMATE
CHANGE CONSTRUCTING WILDFIRE IN
EXOTIC PLANT INFESTATIONS THEY
NEED THE SUPPORT AND FOCUS ON
THE DESERT CONSERVATION PROGRAM
WE PROVIDE IT'S ESTABLISHMENT
WOULD ALSO LEVERAGE FEDERAL
FUNDING. TO CLEAN THE LIGHT OF
THE CURRENT PROPOSAL TO
ESTABLISH A CERTAIN THE
LANDSCAPE IN THE DESERT WHICH
SHOULD BE GOVERNED BY THE
DEPARTMENTS OF DEFENSE INTERIOR
AND AGRICULTURE I STRONGLY URGE
YOUR SUPPORT FOR A BI. ELEVEN
EIGHTY THREE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER DAVIS. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND THEN OF THE
THANK YOU FOR THAT TO GET TAX
FOR A BI ELEVEN EIGHTY THREE MY
NAME IS FOR TRYING BOTH I A CON
PROGRAM ASSISTANT HISPANIC
ACCESS FOUNDATION BENEFACTOR
FOUNDATION IS A NATIONAL
NONPROFIT WITH A MISSION TO
CONNECT LIKE YOU KNOW CLICK
PARTNERS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
IMPROVE LIVES AND CREATE AN
EQUITABLE SOCIETY. CREATING THE
CALIFORNIA DESERT CONSERVATION
PROGRAM IS IMPORTANT TO US OF
CALIFORNIANS UNLIKE YOU KNOW
MANY OF THE COMMUNITIES AND IN
THE CALIFORNIA DESERT ARE LOW
INCOME AND LET YOU KNOW THESE
COMMUNITIES AND ALL COMMUNITIES
WOULD BENEFIT FROM INVESTMENTS
MADE FOR DOES THE CONGREGATION
LATINOS IN CALIFORNIA ARE TWICE
AS LIKELY TO LIVE SOMEWHERE
THAT IS NATURE DEPRIVED THAN
WHITE COMMUNITIES MEANING THEY
HAVE LESS ACCESS TO THE
OUTDOORS AND ARE LESS LIKELY TO
LIVE NEAR EIGHT AND WHILE
MAINTAIN LOCAL PARK. IF
COMMUNITIES RELY ON THAT THAT
THERE ARE ALL THAT CALIFORNIA
HAS TO OFFER IN THE OUTDOOR
RECREATION JUST SIMPLY ENJOYING
THE SCENERY HAVING LEFT NATURE
AND COMPARED OPEN SPACE NEARBY
BEFORE COMMUNITIES OF FOR
HEALTH AND CALL THE NINETEENTH
THE VERY HIGHER STRESS LEVEL
BIRTH EDUCATIONAL OUTCOMES LACK
OF RECREATION AND BUSINESS
OPPORTUNITIES. AND GREATER
VULNERABILITY TO THE IMPACTS OF
CLIMATE CHANGE I HAVE BEEN
BLESSED TO HELP YOU CATCH
HARBINGER HI READING AND
STARGAZING FOR LIKE YOU KNOW
COMMUNITIES IN THE DESERT THE
DESERT REGION OFTEN BLOCKING OF%
AN OPPORTUNITY TO EXPERIENCE
THAT SHE FOUND IN NATURE ET AND
PROVIDE AN ESCAPE THE
MOMENTARILY RELIEVE OUR
FAMILIES FROM THE STRESS THERE
ALL FACING RIGHT NOW. THIS
LEGISLATION WOULD BRING MUCH
NEEDED RESTORATION INCREASED
PUBLIC ACCESS RECREATION
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAM AND CLIMATE
RESILIENT TO THE CALIFORNIA
DOESN'T ENSURE IT WOULD BRING
INCREASED EQUITYFOR
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES NEARBY
WHILE ALSO BENEFITING THE
GLOBAL ENVIRONMENT THANK I FIND
VERY EXCITED TO SUPPORT THIS
LEGISLATION AND STRONGLY URGE
YOU TO SUPPORT IT. THANK YOU SO
MUCH MISS CARRIERS- WE'RE NOW
GOING TO OTHER WITH IN. SEEING
NO IN HERE ROOM TO ANY IN THE-
OTHER. NO LET'S TURN TO LINE.
OFF WITH ANYONE ON THE IN
SUPPORT OF A THREE. YES THEY
YOU LADIES AND GENTS SUPPORT OF
AB ALLOW EIGHTY TWO PLEASED ONE
THEN AT THIS TIME FOR YOU TO GO
TO NUMBER ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BAGHDAD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
DANIEL BROUGHT ON BEHALF OF
SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA AND
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU. MEXICO LINE NUMBER ONE
TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR NUMBERS NIKITA
KARATE WITH NRDC INSTRUCT THE
PARTICULATE AND EIGHTY THREE
THANK YOU. MARK NEXT WOULD LINE
NUMBER ONE TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON NATALIE
MAX ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE PARKS FOUNDATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANKS TO A
LINE NUMBER ONE TWENTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GONZALEZ
POTTER WITH THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB ELEVEN EIGHTY THREE AND
WE TAKE IT FOR THE NUMBER RAMOS
FOR HIS WORK ON THIS ISSUE.
NUMBER NINE NUMBER ONE TWENTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO A DROPPED ONE
CAN IF YOUR SUPPORT OF AB
ELEVEN EIGHTY THREE PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WE GOT A LINE NUMBER ONE
TWENTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN STERN-
CAN DELFINO REPRESENTING
DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE AND THAT
VOICE AS CO SPONSORS OF AB
ELEVEN EIGHTY THREE AND THE
CALIFORNIA NATIVE PLANT SOCIETY
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. AT THIS TIME MISTER
SCHIPPERS WITH NOBODY ELSE IN
Q. OKAY VERY GOOD- WILL NOW
LOOK TURN TO OPPOSITION THERE'S
NONE LISTED ON FILE HERE I'VE
SEEN IT IN THE ROOM OR IN.
ALTERNATIVE LET'S TURN THE
LINES ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
AREA IN OPPOSITION WHICH IN
JUST FIVE. THANK YOU ONCE AGAIN
IF YOU WERE IN OPPOSITION TO AB
ONE ONE EIGHT THREE PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO ON YOUR
TOUCH TONE PHONE. AGAIN THAT'S
OPPOSITION AB ONE ONE EIGHT
THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. MISTER CHAIRPERSON
AT THIS TIME WE HAVE NO ONE IN
Q. VERY GOOD OKAY WILL BRING
BACK TO THE DESK MEMBERS
QUESTIONS COMMENTS MOTIONS.
CHARLIER YOU ARE FROM I JUST
HAD ONE QUESTION ABOUT. BECAUSE
THE ANALYSIS- POINTS OUT THAT
THIS PROGRAM WAS ESTABLISHED
WITHOUT FUNDING. IN OF A NEW
PROBABLY HAD THE ALTERNATIVE
TO- DECIDE TO PURSUE A
CONSERVANCY RATHER THAN THAN
THIS BUT THAT WOULD ABSOLUTELY
REQUIRE FUNDING- WATCH YOUR
KIDS GENERAL DIRECTION WITH
REGARD TO HOW THIS WOULD BE
SUPPORTED BECAUSE THIS IS BEING
PASSED WITHOUT FRONT FUNDING
HOW WOULD YOU. HOPE TO SEE THAT
IT WOULD BE IMPLEMENTED AND
MONEY WOULD FLOW TO THIS SO IN
IN THIS BILL- LAYS THE
GROUNDWORK FOR THAT TO START TO
TAKE PLACE WITH THE FUNDING
PALMER TALKS ABOUT MONEY-
CONTINUING TO MOVE FOR WITH
REVENUE FROM GIVES. DONATIONS
TEN FUNDS APPROPRIATED SO NOT
COUNTING OUT IN THE FUTURE WE
CAN COME BACK AND LOOK FOR SOME
FUNDING THERE BUT AT THIS POINT
GIVES DONATIONS FUNDS
APPROPRIATION FROM THE
LEGISLATURE- AND OTHER SOURCES
OF THOSE- PHILANTHROPIST
PHILANTHROPY TYPES OF FUNDING
AT THIS POINT- IT MIGHT EVEN BE
YOUR TASK INTENT TO FIX IS
PASSED AND SIGNED. TO COME BACK
THROUGH THE BUDGET PROCESS NEXT
YEAR TRY TO FIGURE OUT A WAY TO
HELP BENEFITS ESTABLISHED THAT
IS AN OPTION SO OKAY THANK YOU
BYE I REALLY APPRECIATE YOU
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD AND-
I DIDN'T SEE OTHER HANDS OF
PEOPLE READY I WOULD MOVE THE
BILL VERY GOOD WILL ACCEPT THAT
AS A MOTION AND DO APPRECIATE
THE ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S WORK ON
THIS. AND SEEING SOME ALSO.
OPTIMISTIC SIDE ON THE FED
FRIEND- BOTH THE FEDERAL.
COMMITTEE AROUND- SOME THAT
STAND TO SEE WORK AND THEN- AT
THE SENTINEL LANDSCAPE SO I
THINK THE MOMENTUM IS ON YOUR
SIDE HERE AND I APPRECIATE THAT
COALITION YOU'VE BUILT ON THE-
LAND KNOWLEDGE THAT YOU BRING
TO THIS- FROM HERE ON THE
GROUND. EXPERIENCE I THINK- THE
DEBTOR GETS LEFT BEHIND OFTEN
AND I APPRECIATE YOU FIGHT
ENDED TO PUT THIS LANDSCAPE UP
WHERE IT BELONGS IS ONE OF THE
MOST PRECIOUS IN. CRITICAL
CONSERVATION OPPORTUNITIES
WE'VE GOT SO- THAT'S A MOTION
FROM SENATOR LAYERED IT ALLOW
YOU TO CLOSE. THANK YOU. MR
CHAN THANK YOU FOR THOSE KIND
COMMENTS AND FOR THE QUESTIONS-
THERE THERE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. VERY GOOD- THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED BUT FIRST
AMENDED AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
SHOULD CONSULT WITH YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL FILE ITEM SIX AB
ELEVEN. EIGHTY THREE THE
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS STERN. HI LEARN
ALL RIGHT JONES. ALLEN ALL
RIGHT ALAN ALL RIGHT EGGMAN.
EGGMAN PINE GROVE HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG ALL RIGHT HUESO
LAYERED HI LEARN AYE LIVE ALONE.
HI OKAY THAT MEASURE SIX VOTES
WE WILL LEAVE IT ON CALL FOR
THE ABSENT MEMBERS YES OKAY
THANK YOU SENATOR PRECIADO. I
LAST UP. MARKARIAN. CAN TESLA
COULD NOT NOT THE COURT NOT THE
VEHICLE. THANK YOU AND WELCOME
MEMBERS FIRST I WANT TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE FOR THAT
IMPORTANT DISCUSSIONS ON THE
BILL IN WORKING WITH MY STAFF
I'M HAPPY TO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE'S RECOMMENDED
AMENDMENTS TODAY TODAY PRESENT
AB FIFTEEN TWELVE DISTRICT BILL
THAT WILL PRESERVE A CRITICAL
PIECE OF LAND AND IF THE
ALAMEDA TEST EXPANSION. MOSTLY
ON THE COMMITTEE OF HEARD THIS
BILL BEFORE CENTER WHAT I'M
TALKING ABOUT IT IS ADJACENT TO
CARNEGIE STATE VEHICULAR
RECREATION AREA IN THE LATE
NINETEEN NINETIES THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PARKS
AND RECREATION PURCHASE THE
TEST THE PARK LAND TO EXPAND
OUT THE CARNEGIE HICCUP
VEHICULAR PARK OVER THE
OBJECTIONS. OF THE LOCAL
COMMUNITY. SCIENTIFIC STUDIES
HAVE LONG DOCUMENTED THEIR
ECOLOGICAL VALUE OF THE AREA IT
CONTAINS AN ABUNDANCE OF HIGHLY
SENSITIVE NATIVE BIOLOGICAL
DIVERSITY A CRITICAL HABITAT
CORRIDOR. ALONG THE DIABLO
RANGE UNIQUE VEGETATION AND
WILDLIFE HABITATS THERE AREA
ALSO HOLDS IMPORTANT CULTURAL
RESOURCES LKE THE HISTORIC.
CATHOLIC TOWN IN MINE COMPLEX
FROM WHICH THE LAND GETS ITS
NAME AND SITES IMPORTANT TO
NATIVE PEOPLES. NOW THERE HAS
BEEN A CHANGE SINCE THIS BILL
WAS LAST HEARD. A COMMUNITY IN
THE COUNTY OF ALAMEDA HAVE
FOUGHT FOR YEARS TO PROTECT THE
LAND BUT FINALLY IN JANUARY OF
THIS YEAR. SUPERIOR COURT JUDGE
RULED THAT THE DEPARTMENT'S ER
WAS INVALID. IN RULING THE
JUDGE DETERMINED THAT THE LAND
WOULD BE BEST KEPT IN
PRESERVATION. AB FIFTEEN TWELVE
IS TRYING TO SETTLE THIS
DECADES LONG DISPUTE WHICH I
WOULD POINT OUT HIS. COST TAX
PAYERS SIGNIFICANT RESOURCES TO
FIGHT OVER THIS LAND AND WE
NEED TO JUST RESOLVE IT AND
CALL IT A DAY. SO AB FIFTEEN
TWELVE REQUIRES THE DEPARTMENT
OF PARKS TO PRESERVE THE LAND
THEY CURRENTLY OWN IN
PERPETUITY ONCE NINE MILLION
DOLLARS IN FUNDING IS
APPROPRIATED TRANSFERRED OR
DONATED TO THE OFF HIGHWAY
VEHICLE TRUST FUND. WITH
PLENTIFUL EXISTING LAND FOR
WHICH WE USE IT IS ESSENTIAL TO
PRESERVE THE PRECIOUS NATURAL
RESOURCES AND WILDLIFE THAT
CALL THIS PARK HOME. BY DOING
SO WE WILL ALSO CONTRIBUTE TO
THE GOALS OF THE GOVERNOR'S
EXECUTIVE ORDER OF LAST YEAR TO
PRESERVE 30% OF CALIFORNIA'S
LANCE BY TWENTY THIRTY. IN-SUPPORT OF THE BILL BY PHONE IS
BRANDON DAWSON INTERMIX ACTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE SIERRA CLUB
CALIFORNIA. AND DEALERS ARE YOU
BOARD PRESIDENT EAST BAY
REGIONAL PARK DISTRICT. I THANK
YOU SO MEMBER WE WILL TURN YOUR
LEAST SUPPORTED BELIEVES MISTER
DAWSON- AND THEN I THINK
SOMEONE FROM EAST BAY. PARK
DISTRICT PLEASE PROCEED. GOOD
MORNING SURE MEMBERS BRENDAN
DAWSON DIRECTOR CYNICAL
CALIFORNIA AND ON BEHALF MORE
OF MORE THAN A HALF MILLION
MEMBERS AND SUPPORTERS
STATEWIDE. COOPER DIED IN THE
BAY AREA AND CENTRAL VALLEY I'M
HERE TODAY. A. B. SECTION
TWELVE. BERMAN PRESERVATION OF
THE PARK AT THE TOP
CONSERVATION PRIORITY FOR THE
EAST BAY REGION. AS THE PARK IS
LOCATED IN EASTERN ALAMEDA CA.
AND OVER ONE SUPPORT BUT AT THE
PRESENT. NOT ONLY GET
PROFESSORS AND- ALSO NAY
AMERICAN LEADERS WERE. BECAUSE
PRESERVATION IS ABOUT PUBLIC
AGENCIES SUCH AS THE COUNTY
ALAMEDA DIPLOMA MARCH USED
RESULT DISTRICT. THE
LEGISLATURE OFTEN PASSIVE. TO
SUPPORT LOCAL IN THE- AND
FIFTEEN IS THE- LOOK MEASURE TO
READ. OUR CONTRIBUTION. FOR
OVER HUNDRED PRESERVATION TRUST
OUR ALSO DRAW MATCH BAKER.
PRIORITIES ARE MEMBERS OF IS A
LINE THE GOVERNMENT BY THIRTY
EXECUTIVE ISSUED LAST FALL. THE
PROJECT IS PART OF OUR PROVIDE
CLIMATE CHANGE WITH. PROJECTS
WHILE QUARTER AND A OF DOCTOR
STRANGE. BECAUSE OF WELL AS
SOME. LOCAL TO OUT COUNTY OF UP
WITH LOCAL FUNDS. THE STATE
TROOPERS ARE AT THE PARKING
GARAGE JUDY. IN TWENTY SIXTEEN
BUT WHAT AGE YOU KNOW COUNTY
ABOVE THE NAY. LOCAL UNDER THE
BONTA MALKIN. ARE SPACE ON THE
BASIC AND- TO M. B. DIVISION.
TO PERMANENTLY FROM THE TACKLE.
LOCAL FUNDS TO PAY THE STATE
PROGRAM TO COME. EASEMENT WHICH
THE LINE. OF THE STATE BECAUSE
ORDER TRANSFERRED TO A LOCAL.
ENERGY THE STATE. AYLA SEE HOW
NINE NINE DOLLARS AVAILABLE NOW.
AND THIS IS CREE TO BUY.
AVAILABLE THROUGH THE L. A. O.
L. AS HE FOUGHT THE MONTHLY
WORKING WITH THE LOCAL
COMMUNITY TWITTER TOUGH PARK AT
THE WHEN WIN SOLUTION ENERGY
STATE AND LOCAL POLICY GOALS
FOR TWO EXCEPT NOT A RESOURCE
BY TO PROTECT YOUR BOTTOM
PROJECTS PROVIDES KIND OF
CHANGE REALLY YOU HAVE TO WHILE
ALL IN SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY
BIOLOGIC BURSTING CAL FORTY
THREE WE ARE. TO TALK. THANK
YOU I THINK WE'VE WE'VE THE UP-
TO THEM SO GOT ONE MINUTE LEFT
LEE TEST. RIGHT THANK YOU CAN
HEAR ME YES. THANK YOU I'M DEAD
STERN IS A ARE- FOR THE SPIRIT
PARTISAN AND BOARD. AND WE
REPRESENT TWO POINT SEVEN
MILLION PEOPLE OF ALAMEDA AND
CONTRA COSTA COUNTIES WITH
SEVENTY THREE PARKS HUNDRED
TWENTY ONE THOUSAND ACRES AND
OVER TWO HUNDRED MILES OF TRAIL
ON BEHALF OF THE PARTICIPATES
PRESENCE SUPPORT FOR AB FIFTY
TWELVE TO PRESERVE THE ALAMEDA
TEST EXPANSION AREA BUT THE
CARNEGIE STATE VEHICULAR
RECREATION AREA AND WE ARE
PROUD TO JOIN A NUMBER OF STATE
LOCAL AND ENVIRONMENTAL LEADERS
INCLUDING ALAMEDA COUNTY THE
CITY OF LIVRMORE AND LIVERMORE
AREA RECREATION AND PARK
DISTRICT. IN VIRGINIA'S
COMMITTEE THE LEGISLATURE
GOVERNOR GAVIN NEWSOM AND THE
NATURAL RESOURCES SECRETARY WAY
CRAWFORD TO PRESERVE TESLA AS A
WILDLIFE CORRIDOR FOR SENSITIVE
SPECIES AND TO PROVIDE MORE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR US SENATE
CENTRAL PASSIVE RECREATION.
PARK DISTRICT HAS HISTORICALLY
SUPPORTED PRESENT PRESERVATION
THIS PROPERTY INCLUDING-
DESIGNATING TESSA ON. THE
DISTRICT MASTER PLAN IN TWENTY
THIRTEEN. THE BEAUTIFUL. THIS
IN PLACE TO SAVE A TO A ON OF
THE- OF MINIMUM YOKER AND OR
MONEY KNOWN PEOPLE'S. WHO DOWN
AND CARED THE FAMILIES IN THE
SOUTH LIVERMORE VALLEY AND THE
TOP THE RICH. PRESERVING THE
HERITAGE IS A MEANINGFUL AND
ACKNOWLEDGEMENT THAT THIS RICH
HISTORY IS IMPORTANT TO US NOW
AND FOR FUTURE GENERATIONS WE
COURAGE OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE. THAT'S A RESOURCES AND
WATER COMMITTEE TO PLEASE
APPROVE AB FIFTEEN TWELVE THANK
YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU
I WILL NOW TURN THE GENERAL
SUPPORT- SEEING AN AND THE- BUT
WE HAVE ONE IN THE ROOM. OUR
FIRST FOR THE HEARING. WELCOME
I'M DAVID FREEZER CONSERVATION
CHAIR SAN JOAQUIN AUTO AUDUBON
SOCIETY'S ON ONE CLEAN ON A
BODY SOCIETY STRONGLY SUPPORTS
A. B. THINK WELL THANK YOU FOR
IS JOHN BURTON FOR SECOND BUT A
PRE SHOULDN'T STRESS- THERE WAS
A CERTAIN WORDS THIS. IS INDEED-
WHO LOOKED THE ALTERNATIVE
CHAMBERS NOT NONE THERE- TURN
THE LINES- MAIN SUPPORT- NAME
TITLE AND POSITION ON THE BILL
PLEASE. THANK YOU AN AGENCY OUR
SUPPORT OF AB FIFTEEN TWELVE
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME OR TO GO TO LINE
NUMBER ONE TWENTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON YOU
TELEPHONE TELEPHONE ARE WITH
THE NATURE CONSERVANCY IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB FIFTEEN
TWELVE AND WE WOULD ALIGN
OURSELVES WITH THE COMMENTS
MADE BY OUR COLLEAGUE BRAG
ABOUT THE- CLUB. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. NEXOBRID LINE NUMBER
ONE TWENTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN STERN
KIM DELFINO REPRESENTING
DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE AND THE
CALIFORNIA NATIVE PLANT SOCIETY
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB FIFTEEN
TWELVE. THANKS MISTER B. NEXT.
NEXT TO A LINE NUMBER SIXTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. PINE
SIXTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NEXT TO A LINE NUMBER SIXTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JUAN PABLO
BELTRAN SENIOR LAND USE MANAGER
FOR STATE ON THAT LAND
CONSERVATION SHAREPOINT MOUNT
DIABLO AUDUBON SOCIETY
REPRESENTING OUR TWELVE
THOUSAND MEMBERS WE STATE OUR
STRONG SUPPORT FOR A BI FIFTEEN
TWELVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NEXT NEXT TO A LINE NUMBER
FORTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. I AM
DEAL YET OKAY LEARN ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA NATIVE PLANT
SOCIETY AND STRONG SUPPORT OF
AB FIFTEEN TWELVE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. MEXICO LINE NUMBER
ONE SIXTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THIS IS ARTHUR HALL
REPRESENTING TO ORGANIZATIONS
FRIENDS OF LIVERMORE IN
LIVERMORE HILL HIKERS IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB FIFTEEN TWELVE.
THANK YOU. THANKS TO A LINE
NUMBER FIFTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS WILL BOLTON
PRESIDENT OF THE MORE HERE
KILLED WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB FIFTEEN TWELVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NEXT WOULD LINE
NUMBER SEVENTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
BACKWARDS BURKE WITH THE EAST
BAY CHAPTER OF THE CALIFORNIA
NATIVE PLANT SOCIETY STRONG
SUPPORT AT FIFTEEN TWELVE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXAVAR LINE NUMBER FORTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS CHAD ARE CREE- CONSERVATION
COMMITTEE CHAIR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA NATIVE GRASSLANDS
ASSOCIATION- AND WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT A. B. FIFTEEN TWELVE-
WE'VE LOST 99% OF OUR NATIVE
GRASSLANDS ONLY 1% REMAINS
WOULD LIKE TO SEE A MALL.
PRESERVED THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NEXAVAR LINE NUMBER ONE TWENTY
EIGHT ONE MOMENT. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS TAMERA
ROYCE- WITH FRIENDS OF THE OPEN
SPACE IN THE NEAR TO BASED IN
THE LIVERMORE AREA AND WE ARE
IN VERY STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
LEGISLATION THANK YOU. THANKS
SO MUCH. MEXICO LINE NUMBER ONE
TEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M JOHN
TAYLOR PROFESSOR OF
MICROBIOLOGY AT UC BERKELEY I
SUPPORT AB FIFTEEN TWELVE
BECAUSE IT WILL PROTECT
CALIFORNIA'S FROM VALLEY FEVER
A SEVERE FUNGAL DISEASE THAT
I'VE STUDIED FOR THIRTY YEARS
THE TEMPLE SITE IS AN AREA
KNOWN TO HARBOR THE VALLEY
FEVER FUNDING. WORKERS TO
CONSTRUCT THE OUTSIDE HI WE
GIVE A PARK AND THOSE WHO USE
THE PARK WILL BE DANGEROUSLY
EXPOSED TO THE DISEASE I
APPRECIATE THE NEED FOR- HD
RECREATIONS I DON'T HAVE CLASS
WHICH I THINK IT WAS ON A
BILLABLE. NOTED AS SUPPORT
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANKS TO A
LINE NUMBER ONE NINETEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. PINE ONE NINETEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANKS TO A
LINE NUMBER ONE TWENTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO I'M
MARYLAND LAST FALL I FIFTY YEAR
RESIDENT COUNCIL ROAD- TEACHER
OF BIOLOGIST PRESIDENT ALAMEDA
COUNTY RESOURCE CONSERVATION
DISTRICT. READ OUT THE EAST
ALAMEDA- THE RANCHERS AND WE
VERY STRONGLY SUPPORT ASSEMBLY
BILL ONE FIVE SEVEN THREE WE
HAVE CONTINUOUS PROPERTY AND SO
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT TO US
IMPASSIVE YOU REALLY APPRECIATE
IT THANK YOU. THANKS TO A LINE
NUMBER ONE THIRTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. CUNNINGHAM A BROAD
CALIFORNIA BASED NONPROFIT FOR
AND BEGIN COMPENSATION AND
SUPPORT FOR AB ONE ONE Q. THANK
YOU. MEXICO LINE NUMBER ONE
TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE
ONE TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. WE'LL GO TO LINE NUMBER
ONE THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
GOOD AFTERNOON COMMITTEE
MEMBERS TIME JENNIFER SPENCER
PRESENTED OF FOR THE SOCIETY OF
AMERICAN INDIANS THE NUMBER
MARCH AND WE ARE IN VERY STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB FIFTEEN TWELVE
FOR ALL THE RETWEETS MENTIONS
BUT ESPECIALLY FOR ALL OF THE
INSURANCE RESTORED MAKE
AMERICAN ARTIFACT INCLUDED
IRREPLACEABLE THE GREAT GERMANY
ALL AN. ARCHAEOLOGICAL AND
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OKAY WE'RE
JUST DO IT FOR THOSE CONTENT
FIVE GONNA DO. AND WITH YOUR-
AND WHETHER YOU SUPPORT THE
BILL THAT'S ALL THANK YOU SO
MUCH NEXT NEXT WITNESS. THE
NEXT TWENTY FOUR LINE NUMBER
EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS PAT GORDON REPRESENTING
ALONI AUDUBON SOCIETY OF
SOUTHERN. SOUTHEASTERN ALAMEDA
COUNTY AND THE CITIZENS
COMMITTEE TO. COMPLETE THE
REFUGE WE STRONGLY URGE STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB FIFTEEN TWELVE
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH.
NEXT TO A LINE NUMBER FORTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. FINUCANE
PRESIDENT OF LIVERMORE
CALIFORNIA STRONGLY SUPPORTS AB
SIXTEEN TWELVE THANK YOU OKAY
THANKS SO MUCH. CONNECT TO A
LINE NUMBER ONE NINETEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. NINE ONE NINETEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANKS TO A
LINE NUMBER EIGHTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. SENATOR SPEAKING FOR
THE ALBEMARLE PLAN STILL OPEN
SPACE COMMITTEE THE OPEN SPACE
COMMITTEE HAS THE NINE MILLION
CALLED FOR IN AB FIFTEEN TWELVE
AND STRONGLY SUPPORTS THIS BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THANKS TO
A LINE NUMBER EIGHTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS CELESTE CARAMANDI.
EKING ON BEHALF OF THE
GREENBELT ALLIANCE REGIONAL
PARK ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA
WILDLIFE FOUNDATION IN
CALIFORNIA OAKS FOUNDATION AND
LASTLY THE ALAMEDA CREEK
ALLIANCE IN STRONG SUPPORT AB
ONE FIVE ONE TWO. THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT. THANKS FOR ANY
GO TO LINE NUMBER ONE TWENTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINE ONE
TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
AND ONCE AGAIN MADE IN GENERAL
IF YOUR SUPPORT OF AB ONE FIVE
ONE TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME ONE CANNOT
SUPPORT FOR AB ONE FIVE ONE TWO
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. I WANT TO GO BACK TO LINE
NUMBER ONE TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. LINE ONE TWENTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. NINE ONE TWENTY
SIX. LET'S MOVE ON LET'S MOVE
ON OPERATOR B. THANK YOU BE
JUST ONE MORE MOMENT PLEASE. BE
JUST ANOTHER MOMENT. BE JUST
ANOTHER MOMENT. APOLOGIZE FOR
THE DELAY WILL BE JUST ONE MORE
MOMENT. IS THERE. FOR ZERO.
POINT GO TO LINE NUMBER ONE
THIRTY TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS
IS JOHN LEWIS FROM CASTRO
VALLEY CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING
THE HUDDLE GROUP IN CASTRO
VALLEY. ALAMEDA COUNTY AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT. ONE FIVE ONE
TWO THANK YOU THANK YOU. MISTER
CHAIR PERSON AT THIS TIME WE
HAVE NOBODY ELSE IN Q. OKAY
VERY GOOD WILL TURN OUT TO- ANY
OPPOSITION. DO YOU HAVE ANY IN
THE- CHAMBERS I THINK OUR LEAD
UP THIS WILL BE AMY GREEN NOT.
FROM THE OFF ROAD VEHICLE
LEGISLATION LEGISLATIVE
COALITION. AND GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN STERN COMMITTEE
MEMBERS IN THE GRANITE OFF ROAD
VEHICLE LEGISLATIVE COALITION
THE SIMPLE TRUTH AB FIFTEEN
TWELVE INVOLVES THOSE WITH
WEALTH AND POLITICAL
CONNECTIONS THINKING TO TAKE
AWAY LAND AN OPPORTUNITY FROM
EVERY DAY CALIFORNIANS CONTRARY
TO ALL THAT HAS BEEN SAID. HAS
SHOWN THAT MANY OF THE
PARTICIPANTS IN MOTORI
RECREATION TO THE CARNEGIE AREA
COME FROM THE CENTRAL VALLEY
FROM TRADITIONALISTS ADVANTAGE
COMMUNITIES. WITH OVER 40%
BETWEEN THE AGES OF TWENTY FIVE
AND FORTY EIGHT IDENTIFYING AS
HISPANIC. THIS ISSUE IS NO
DIFFERENT FROM THOSE WITH
WEALTH AND POWER WOULD SEEK TO
PRIVATIZE NAY JASINSKI EACH TO
THEIR BEEF BEACHFRONT HOMES IN
ORDER TO DEPRIVE ACT THAT THE
AVERAGE CITIZEN. WE'VE ALL
HEARD AND BEEN APPALLED BY THE
STORY THE WEALTHY POLITICALLY
CONNECTED INDIVIDUALS LOCAL
CURRENTLY CARNEGIE INITIALLY
SIGNED OFF ON THE PURCHASE OF
THE LAND BY THE DELHI TREE
TRUST FUND AND DEDICATED ONLY
TO BE RECOGNITION. PURCHASED
WITH THE MONEY IN THE TRUCKS
DERIVE SOLELY FROM FEES PAID BY
THE OXFORD COMMUNITY. NOW HE'S
WEALTHY AND POWERFUL
INDIVIDUALS ARE SEEKING TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THEIR
OPPORTUNITIES WHO PAID FOR THIS
PARK AB FIFTY TWELVE PROPOSES
TO CREATE A DE FACTO EXCLUSIVE
PRESERVE. SOLELY DEVELOP
PRIVATE AGENDA BY THE WEALTHY
AND POWERFUL THE FACT WILL
DEPRIVE CHILDREN AND THEIR
FAMILIES WHO PAID FOR THE PARK
WITH THEIR HARD EARNED MONEY
THE OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE FUN AND
ENJOY A DAY IN THE STATE PARK.
DOING WHAT THEY LOVE TO DO. THE
SAME LOCAL INDIVIDUALS HAVE THE
MONEY TO CONSTANTLY FILE
LAWSUITS COSTING THE TAXPAYERS
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS IN ORDER
TO HAMSTRING STATE PARKS IN THE
MANAGEMENT OF THIS AREA SIMPLY
PUT THEY'LL DO ANYTHING TO GET
THEIR WAY. BUT AVERAGE
CALIFORNIANS CAN'T FILE
LAWSUITS HERE A FEW YEARS
SEEKING THEIR RIGHTS TO ENJOY
STATE PARK IN THE MANNER THAT
EVERYDAY HARD WORKING
CALIFORNIANS MAKES. BUT WEALTHY
AND POLITICALLY CONNECTED
SHOULD NOT HAVE THE POWER TO
USURP THE RIGHTS OF EVERY DAY
CALIFORNIANS BUT THIS IS A GOOD
EXACTLY WHAT THE SUBJECT OF AB.
FIFTEEN TWELVE ACCOMPLISHES. AS
TOUGH AS IT IS TO SPEAK TO
POWER. SB FIFTY TWELVE ISN'T
THE AND- IN END IF ABOUT
ENDANGERED SPECIES.BECAUSE WE
HAVE AN NAY THE PAR APART AND
REC. THAT COULD NT AND WOULD
NOT ALLOW ANY. ARE TO BE TO.
QUITE THE- THEY PROTECT NATURAL
CULTURAL RESOURCES AND ALLSTATE.
REGARDLESS OF ALLOWED ACTIVITY.
THE PROJECTED USE OF THIS PARK
WITH ITS CURRENT DESIGNATION
WOULD PICK UP. TEN OF THE TOTAL
LAND MASS ONLY 10% WHILE
ALLOWING CHILDREN AND FAMILIES
FROM THE CENTRAL VALLEY AND BAY
AREA TO HAVE FUN IN THE SAFE
ENVIRONMENT. AND ALLOWING
DISABLED PEOPLE TO CAMP IN A
BUILDING MORE WILDERNESS
ENVIRONMENT WHICH GIVES THE-
PARK DOES NOT OFFER THROUGHOUT
THEIR PARK IN THE BAY. AREA WE
FURTHER ENVIRONMENT PER.
MEASURES AND THAT'S WHAT. AB
TWO FOR THE ONLY. AS AN AVENUE
TO HER THE P. OF PAID FOR THE
PER. AND PAID TWENTY YEARS AND
MANAGEMENT OF THIS PROPERTY
BECAUSE THESE PEOPLE JUST LIKE
ME. SEVENTEEN BY WEALTHY AND
POWERFUL PEOPLE TO BE
EXTRANEOUS UNNECESSARY AND
UNIMPORTANT. WELL THE NEED TO
THE WEALTHY- SEEMINGLY TAKES
CENTER STAGE IN EIGHTEEN
FIFTEEN TWELVE. THE NEED THE
NEED TO THE EVERYDAY
CALIFORNIANS ARE BEING
DISCARDED. THANK YOU THANKS SO
MUCH FOR TESTIMONY. WILL NOW
TURN TO ANY ONE ELSE WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION I DON'T
SEE ANYONE IN THE HEARING ROOM
OR IN THE ALTERNATE- SO WE'LL
TURN THE LINES OPPORTUNITY IF
ANYONE WANTS TESTIFIED IN
OPPOSITION. TO ONE FIVE ONE
TWO. THANK YOU IF YOU WERE IN
OPPOSITION AB ONE FIVE ONE TWO
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME ON YOUR TOUCH TONE
PHONE. WHEN YOU GO LINE NUMBER
ONE OH EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES THIS IS NICHOLAS HARRIS
WESTERN STATES REPRESENTATIVE
FOR THE AMERICAN MOTORCYCLIST
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU NEXT.
MEXICO LINE NUMBER ONE TWENTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON THAT UNDER CERTAIN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE KATHY
RANCH REPRESENTING THE OFF ROAD
VEHICLE LEGISLATIVE IN A
STATEWIDE ORGANIZATION IN
STRONG OPPOSITION THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANKS FOR THE
TESTIMONY. ANY OTHERS. NEXT TO
A LINE NUMBER ONE THIRTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH APOLOGIES
CAL CHAIRED MEMBERS ONE OF
ANOTHER REPRESENTING ALLEN
ACCOUNTING SUPPORT I CAN GET IN
ON THE COMPUTER SCIENCE THANK
YOU SO MUCH OKAY GREAT THANK
YOU ONE OF THAT. SIX OF THE
LINE NUMBER SIXTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. BY NUMBER SIXTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MEXICO LINE
NUMBER ONE THIRTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MISTER CHAIRMAN MADE
CAME FROM PART OF THE APPLE
BETA CALIFORNIA OPPOSED THE
BILL WE HAVEN'T SEEN THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WERE PUT IN THE
BILL IF THEY'RE GOING TO PUT
THE FIFTY FOUR MILLION DOLLARS
OKAY WHICH IS THE PROPER AMOUNT
TO PURCHASE THE LAND. THERE
THAT THE LAND VALUE UNDERSTOOD
WE'RE GOING TO NURTURE
OPPOSITION AND THANK YOU FOR
THAT. THANKS SO MUCH. ONCE
AGAIN LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION AB ONE
FIVE ONE TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO ON YOUR TOUCH
TONE PHONE AGAIN THAT'S
OPPOSITION AB ONE FIVE ONE TWO
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
BORDERLINE NUMBER SIXTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE YOU ARE TRACK OKAY
VICE CHAIR OF THE ALAMEDA
COUNTY DEMOCRATIC PARTY CHAIR
AT THE CALIFORNIA DEMOCRATIC
PARTY ENVIRONMENTAL CAUCUS I
WHO WISH TO APOLOGIZE SOME
REASON I COULD NOT GET IN IN
SUPPORT AT THE WHITE TIME- THAT
STATE AND BE COUNTY PARTY ARE
BOTH IN TALKS OF THE
LEGISLATION THAT YOUR SUPPORT
THANK YOU. APPRECIATE IT THANK
YOU YOUR OTHERS IN OPPOSITION
NOW'S THE TIME. MISTER
CHAIRPERSON HAVE KNOWN ALL
SECURE THIS TIME OKAY VERY GOOD
WILL BRING BACK TO THE DICE
THAN MEMBERS COMMENTS QUESTIONS
AS HE CENTER LAYERED. BUT JUST
A OF A COMMON QUESTION AND- THE
COMMENT IS TO IT. FOR TEN YEARS
MY ADVICE TO HOLD SECESSION
SUCCESSION OF LEGISLATORS IS
THAT THE WAY TO SUCCESSFULLY
ACCOMPLISH THIS. IS TO BUY OUT
DEAL WHICH FEE FUND AND THAT'S
WHAT THE SEPARATE DOLLARS AND
THAT. MAKES TOTAL SENSE MY
QUESTION IS THAT WE PASSED OUT
A BILL BY SENATOR GLAZERS
EARLIER IN THE SESSION THAT WAS
SIMILAR. AND THERE'S A BUDGET
REQUEST FOR THIS THAT IS
DIFFERENT TELL US. HOW ALL
THREE OF THESE FIT TOGETHER AND
WHAT THE STATUSES. YES AT MY
UNDERSTANDING ALTHOUGH I DON'T
LIKE TO SPEAK FOR THE
LEGISLATORS THE SENATOR GLAZERS
LEGISLATION IS NOT MOVING AT
THIS TIME SO THIS IS THE ONLY
PIECE OF LEGISLATION THAT
REMAINS MOVING. AND YES
ALTHOUGH THE BUDGET SEEMS LIKE
A PERFECTLY REASONABLE PLACE TO
DO THIS EXCHANGE. WE ARE DOING
IT THROUGH THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS AT THIS TIME MEDINA IS
THAT MEANS THAT YOU DON'T THINK
THE BUDGET RQUEST IS MOVING A
LITTLE IT WAS IN AS YOU MAY
KNOW IS IN THE BUDGET WE PASSED
INITIALLY I WAS NOT IN THE
BUDGET THAT WE PASSED. LAST
WEEK I LOST TRACK OF TIME-
WHATEVER THIS THAT AGREED UPON
BUDGET WISE SO IT IS NO LONGER
IN THE BUDGET LANGUAGE ON- THAT
SAYS A LOT IF IT WAS IN THE TWO
PARTY AGREEMENT AND NOT A THREE
PARTY AGREEMENT THAT. THAT IS A
STATEMENT I WOULD MOVE THE BILL
THANK YOU FOR RESPONDING
SENATORS THANK YOU CENTER ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS. YES
MISS RESTAURANT. TEACHER I AS
SOON THANK YOU- AT- MY-
POSITION ON THE- BEEN. PRETTY
CLEAR ALL ALONG- EVEN WHEN I
WAS I THE ASSEMBLY. BUT TO
CONCERNS PARTICULARLY ON THIS
BILL REGARDING THE NINE MILLION
DOLLARS. ONE IS IT DIRECTS
PARKS TO GET THE NINE MILLION
DOLLARS BUT IT DOESN'T REALLY.
PRESENT A SOLID GUARANTEE. THAT
THAT'S GONNA HAPPEN SO I JUST
WANT YOU COULD SPEAK TO THAT-
AND THEN NINE MILLION DOLLARS
IN NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT JUST
ON. ST INFLATION IS WORTH
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS- ONE OF
THE- OPPONENTS SPOKE ABOUT
FIFTY FOUR MILLION DOLLARS I
DON'T KNOW YOU KNOW WHAT LAND
IS DONE AND I'M SURE IT'S GONNA
WELL I KNOW IT'S KIND OF A LOT
I DON'T KNOW WHAT HOW MUCH BUT
IT. CERTAINLY BE TO SOMEWHERE
BETWEEN FIFTEEN AND FIFTY FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS IT WOULD BE THE
RIGHT NUMBER SO I JUST WANT HOW
YOU. YOU KNOW HI HOW YOU
ARRIVED TO THE NINE MILLION
DOLLARS WITHOUT. YOU KNOW I
COUNTING FOR INFLATION OR
GROWTH OF THE LAND VALUE YES
SELAHATTIN HAVE INTEREST BOTH
THOSE QUESTIONS CENTER THANK
YOU SO THE FIRST ONE IS THE
BILL SAYS THAT IT WILL BE
PRESERVED ONCE THE MONEY IS
RECEIVED SO I THINK THAT
GUARANTEES THAT IF THE MONEY'S
NOT RECEIVED THE LAND WILL NOT
BE PRESERVED IN PERPETUITY SO
HOPEFULLY THAT ADDRESSES YOUR
FIRST CONCERN AS FOR YOUR
SECOND CONCERN- WE ACTUALLY
HAVE THE BENEFIT OF A RECENT
LANDS- FOR SALE JUST SOUTH AND
ADJACENT TO. THIS LAND TO THE
M. THREE PROPERTY WENT ON THE
MARKET AND HAS BEEN ACTUALLY
JUST HAD AN OFFER PUT ON IT AND
THAT LAND WHICH IS VERY SIMILAR
IN NATURE SO THIS PLAN IS NOT
AVAILABLE IN FACT ALAMEDA
COUNTY PASSED A- PROPOSITION.
SAID THAT YOU COULD NOT DEVELOP
THIS LAND SO IT DOES NOT HAVE
THE SAME VALUE AS YOUR TYPICAL
EVEN LAND IN LIVERMORE- AND SO
IT DOES NOT HAVE WHAT I THINK.
THE VALUE THAT IS BEING
PROPOSED BY THE OPPOSITION AND
IN FACT. AND THREE WHICH WAS
APPRAISED APPRAISED AT ONE
THOUSAND DOLLARS AN ACRE. AND
IF YOU WERE TO DO THE MATH ON
THIS LAND AT THAT WOULD BE
THREE MILLION DOLLARS SO IN
FACT. BASED ON THAT APPRAISAL I
BELIEVE THE NINE MILLION
DOLLARS IS GENEROUS. BUT
THERE'S NO QUESTION THAT
DOESN'T HAVE A FIFTY MILLION
DOLLAR VALUE. ON THE END THREE.
PROPERTY WHICH IS FIFTY MILLION
ACRES A FIFTY THOUSAND ACRES AS
OPPOSED TO THIS THREE THOUSAND.
WITH THE PRICE OF FIFTY
MILLION. IT'S IN THREE IS OR IT
ISN'T THREE IS LAND JUST SOUTH.
OKAY THANK YOU. SEEN NO FURTHER
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FOR
MEMBERS- AS THE- NEPHEW OF A
RANCHER AND TRACY AND FAMILY AT
LIVERMORE AND- I DON'T KNOW IF
SHE'S PART OF THE SAVE THE
FROGS COALITION WITH THE FACT
THAT YOU HAVE. RANCHERS AND-
PEOPLE WHO ARE LOOKING OUT FOR
CRITTERS AND THE FOREIGN FAUNA
IS BEEN A LONG TIME COMING
HERE- SO. WISH YOU WELL ON THIS
JOURNEY AND WILL BE SUPPORTING
THE MEASURE TODAY I WOULD
ENTERTAIN A MOTION AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. ABSENT
LAYERED IS A MOTION AND- WE-
LIVE CLOSE. THANK YOU ARE
RESPECTFULLY ASK DR THAT VERY
GOOD THANKS TO THE MOTION IS. A
DO PASS AS AMENDED THE FIRST
AMENDED RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE AND APPROPRIATIONS
CHIEF CONSULTANTS CALL THE ROLL
FILE ITEM SEVEN AV FIFTEEN
TWELVE THE MOTIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
STERN. HI ALL RIGHT JONES JONES
NO ALLEN. ALLEN HI EGGMAN. HER
I'M GROVE HURTS BY HEARD HIGH.
LATER ON LITTERED I. LIMóN ALL
RIGHT THE MEASURE HAS FIVE
VOTES WILL ON CALL THE ABSENT
THANK YOU SO MUCH ASSEMBLY.
MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO HOPE THE
ROLE ON THE OUTSTANDING ITEMS
FOR THOSE WHO HAVE NOT YET
ADDED ON I DON'T THINK WE HAVE.
EVERYONE HERE BUT- FOR THE
BENEFIT OF THOSE HERE WILL WILL
RE OPEN- WHO ALL OF US ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR CHIEF
CONSULTANT. OKAY THE CONSENT
CALENDAR FILE ITEM ONE AB
SEVENTY TWO FILE ITEM FOR A. B.
SIX NINE TO. THE CURRENT VOTE
IS FIVE ZERO. GROWTH HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG BY HUESO HI HUESO ALL
LIMóN. LIMóN HI THAT HAS
EIGHT THAT'S THAT MEASURES OUT
CLOSE THE ROLE FILE ITEM NUMBER
TWO EIGHTY FOUR FOUR TWO MAYES.
FILE ITEM TO A FOUR FORD TO
MAYES TWO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS GROVE HERTZBERG
HERTZBERG HIGHWAY SO HUESO LOAN.
LIMóN HI THAT'S EIGHT OUT-
CLOSE ROLE- HUNDRED TEN NUMBER
THREE B. FIVE NINE A RAM OKAY
FINE THREE AB FIVE FIVE NINE
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS THE
CURRENT VOTE IS FOUR TO ONE.
GROVE HERTZBERG. FIVE HUESO
HUESO ARE LIMóN. LONE RIGHT
SKIRMISHERS OUT- FOR NUMBER
FIVE AB EIGHT NINE BENNETT.
FILE ITEM FIVE A NINE EIGHT
SAID I'M SORRY NINE. BECAUSE
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS THE CURRENT
POTUS FIVE ZERO JONES GROVE
HUESO HI HUESO ALL RIGHT LOAN
LIMóN HI AND ONCE AFTER THAT
MEASURES OUT. TO FIND SIX AB
ELEVEN EIGHTY THREE THIS IS
FILE ITEM SIXTY B. ELEVEN EIGHT
EIGHTY THREE THE MOTIONS TO
PASS THIS TO AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS OCCURRED VOTE IS
SIX ZERO JONES GROVE HUESO. HI
IS. FELLOW SIX SIX YEAH THAT
THE. SIX THAT'S OKAY SEVEN THEM
OUT AND LAST FIVE IN SEVEN B.
ONE FIVE TWO BY QUE WELL IT
SEVEN- ARE AB TWELVE OH TO AS A
TO A- THE CURRENT BILL FIVE ONE
EGGMAN. EGGMAN HI HUESO. PLEASE.
DID WE LOSE AMERICA. OKAY THIS
VISIBILITY OF COURSE I THINK
WE'VE THE VISION TO VOTE FOR
THAT MAY TO BE OUT SO WE CLOSE
ROLE ON THAT AND WITH THAT
BUSINESS YEAR IS COMPLETE WILL
CHURN ST NATCH RESEARCH AND
WATER THANK MEMBERS. THERE ARE
SOME.